Well you go through all three of those?
No.
Okay.
Well no one other ones for you.
Oh okay,
good.
Good.
Cause all that gas based gone through three cow alive
is figuring out how much I think these are 270 milligrams of caffeine.
If you drank three of these Jamie,
that would kill you right there.
Cool.
Yeah.
No,
it wouldn't kill Ya.
Fuck you up.
I thought you walked in with three copies.
I was like,
God Damn Rogan.
You're going to die like straight up.
Tie Up to a show.
What is for you?
Hopefully we won't need both.
Wow.
I Dunno.
I've drank both of them before the show,
which is like 500 plus milligrams.
I'm addicted to coffee though,
man.
I will just drink it when I'm,
I don't even need a high,
I'll just drink it.
I love the smell of it.
It's so good in the morning,
man.
It's the best.
I love it with cream.
I love it.
Black.
I Love Espresso.
I love it all.
See I got rid of drinking the whole coffee.
I'm now an espresso drinker.
Really?
Two shots in the morning.
A double shot,
a double shot,
and then like a couple hours later,
another day I'll do like eight double shots throughout the day because to me
that's better than drinking one coffee.
Yes,
but it's not.
It's not.
It's actually,
apparently espresso has less caffeine in it then coffee does.
Even though it seems like it has a lot.
It does it,
but you have to drink more acidic.
Yeah.
He's like shit,
but it's definitely an acquired taste.
I enjoy it,
but it's one of the rare things I drank to is that big and I'm holding my finger
up like two inches inches.
Yeah,
it's that.
It's two inches and it'll take me 10 15 minutes.
Drink it for an espresso.
Yeah.
It should be like a s a slow.
My God.
Why are you drinking so slow?
I like it.
I like to say grow like the gentleman pinkies out.
There's only one way to do it with these fat neanderthals.
If you're holding that little tiny though,
you can't get your whole hand in there like a mega man drinking an espresso.
Right.
It's not like a beer Stein that of,
oh,
a rhino horn.
It's a tiny little thing.
You can not look tough drink.
I'm an expert but I drink mine.
I'm like three seconds till you just pound them and then I'll go to the gym.
Well I do that too.
One time I uh,
I drank five,
I have an espresso espresso maker and I put five capsules in there and filled a
mug up with it.
Like a coffee mug
and I ran four miles.
No,
it wasn't as fucking animal through the hills.
Like I was being chased by wolves.
Just Holly,
fuck am I chasing you?
I was like,
why did I drink so much?
So what is the espresso at?
What does it say there Jamie?
Okay.
Coffee brewed.
See,
but then it all is all depends on the company because Starbucks is extremely
caffeinated.
Yeah.
See Starbucks is way up the chart.
Look at it there.
Starbucks tall is closing in on 200 and it looks like about two 70 somewhere in
the range of 270 milligrams caffeine.
But that's a coffee.
That's not coffee.
It would be better to go to Starbucks and get a tall coffee,
but there's an espresso.
See how low it is?
It's below a hundred yeah,
so that's why I'm drinking so many.
So when I drank five,
I guess,
I think I had fun.
I paid 500 milligrams,
which is basically less than drinking two of these things.
Yeah.
These Caveman Nitros.
These are the shit.
Yeah.
I live off these goddamn things.
They're responsible for half my productivity.
Basically.
I'm too chicken shit to go on Adderall.
So I just,
I just drink this stuff all day.
He's good move,
good move.
I,
there's nothing wrong with coffee,
man.
I'm scared of Adderall.
But people will admit they're alert,
they're addicted to coffee and everyone's like,
God,
me too.
If you go,
dude,
I am so addicted to Adderall.
They're like,
okay Joe,
not calling you,
are you?
You're going to think I'm lame.
But till five years ago,
I didn't even know what Adderall,
it was good.
No,
I think you're smart.
I like all my friends in Houston.
They do it and I asked my friend,
like I texted him and I go,
hey man,
what you got?
What's your Auntie?
And he goes,
yeah,
we got Adderall.
I was like,
what are you know your address to go to your house?
Like literally he thought it was talking about Adderall and then he splayed to
me like when you're in a club and you want to stay up and you want to stay like
energized,
you take Adderall.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
But I,
I don't drink so I can stay up until three,
four o'clock in the morning,
be fine.
What's fascinating about Adderall is what they've essentially done is taken an
amphetamine and made it so that if you prescribe it for a condition,
right?
Like they give it to people who have add is one of them,
write whatever the fuck that means.
And it's very debatable whether or not you have it or don't have,
everybody has a upon,
I have it for sure.
If it's real,
if it's real,
I haven't,
but they give you Adderall.
Yeah,
just fucking speed.
And because it's a medication that you give to somebody who has supposedly has a
condition.
And by the way,
I'm not diagnosing you.
If you're out there,
you're getting frustrated with me right now.
Just listen to me.
It's fucking speed.
Maybe you need speed.
Maybe you're that person that needs speed.
Maybe you do need it legitimately as a medication,
but there's off fuck gloated he pulled at her just doing speed.
So by somebody giving you speed,
it's supposed to slow you down.
So you want to have add.
Is that the reason they say legit?
If you have the legit add look,
I am not doubting that.
Some people have what a hundred buck I have worse than I have it.
Yeah,
there's a spectrum right,
with everything.
But for some people when they take Adderall or similar type of substances,
it actually lets them focus and they can,
they can actually be on track.
So by speeding it up somehow it focuses edit.
I think it's,
I think the idea is that it's proof that their system is wired wrong,
which is why when you give them that speed,
they can send her out and mellow out.
My,
uh,
my friend's a doctor and I was talking to him and I used to,
you know,
just popped by to say what's up.
And he goes,
hey man,
just to let you know,
the more you go to a doctor,
the faster you'll die.
And I go,
what?
Yeah.
He's like,
I just want to let know.
Yeah.
He says,
the more you go to us,
you come to us,
the faster
you'll die.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
Because a lot of doctors are crooked and they'll give you something for what you
think you got.
And then after that wears off,
they have to give you some mouse.
So now you just keep filling yourself with stuff to fix.
The other thing that was wrong,
and he goes,
some,
some doctors are not good people.
And he goes,
the more people go to doctors the fast day.
Dot.
Put it in point.
My Mom beat breast cancer twice.
Right.
And my dad's never been to the doctor.
He's 75 years old.
Never been to the doctor wants cause he's like,
well soon as you go to the doctor they tell you something wrong,
you die,
you know literally.
But if you have cancer you should go to a fucking,
he didn't have cancer.
My mom did.
Right.
But if he had cancer he should go to a fucking,
but I don't think he would go even if he has.
Yeah,
he's just,
my mom beat it twice and she's still here?
Yes she is.
In the second time she beat it.
She didn't even tell me she had it.
It doesn't your dad want to beat it if he gets it.
This kind of dude was like,
Hey,
I've been through a lot.
I'm fine.
Like he's,
he hates going to the doctor.
They'll only time you went to the doctor.
He had a back problem and that's it.
That's old score.
What have you met?
A good doctor.
Like a doctor that he likes.
Like a guy who plays golf with or some shit like my dad.
My Dad is not social.
It's not.
No,
no,
no.
I'm totally weird.
You're so social.
I,
I'm totally opposite.
Like my dad's story is crazy.
Like he,
you know,
he went through segregation.
He got a phd in nuclear physics.
Oh yeah.
My Dad's a genius,
but shit,
by out there talking shit on,
just tell it,
judge,
I'm a failure,
but you're not because you're a success at it.
So he's got to go all right.
Yeah.
He knows.
He's the one that told me to drop out of college.
Really?
Yeah.
I played football for these many.
Say it though.
He said you need to drop out of college.
You're not smart.
Like not
Michael.
You need to drop out of college and chase your dream.
Oh No,
no,
no.
He was like,
my dad's whole thing is I got a phd in nuclear physics.
I know what wanting to be in school is,
and you don't want to be in school and you,
you got a personality,
go do that.
But you're dumb.
Like,
oh.
He would say that.
My parents were not supportive.
They were just not support.
Like my mom wanted me to be a doctor,
but she knew I wasn't bright enough to be a doctor.
So like my dad said,
you've got to drop out.
I see.
I don't think you're not bright enough to be a doctor.
I think you're not interested in being a doctor.
See Cause I see how you pursue stand up and show business.
You're,
you're a bright,
ambitious guy.
Still want to be operating on people that are on anesthesia.
It's fucking headlamps on and shit and rubber gloves covered with blood kit
though.
I don't,
fuck,
I don't want nobody dying on me.
That would be the worst.
Having somebody die while you're working on them and then you got to go tell
their friends,
hey man,
sorry.
My bad.
You know.
Ah,
the pressure of those people.
Jamie was he,
he was telling me yesterday about the guy who's the EMT who sees,
tell me,
tell me what you told me.
He's a,
he said he was listening to the podcast we did with Louis J.
Gomez about people getting head injuries.
Uh,
and he has been doing,
I believe for like 15 years or so.
Like it doesn't do it every single day because you don't every single day,
but on a
three day basis or so,
every day he works,
he sees at least one person dead from a head injury,
whether it's an elderly person,
they slipped on ice,
something people fall and hit their heads.
Oh yeah.
That's why.
Please folks,
if you're listening to me and you want to punch somebody in,
knocked them out,
please don't do it.
Just go to a gym,
get your frustrations out.
Don't fight on the street.
You could kill somebody or you can get killed even accidentally.
Even if you really don't hate the guy that much,
you punched him in the face.
They go unconscious,
their head hits the ground.
People die all the time.
In mean.
I've told the story about when Kevin James used to work as a bouncer in Long
Island,
a guy that he was working with punched the guy and killed them.
Really?
Yeah.
Kevin.
Kevin wasn't there,
but he knew the guy and the guy accidentally killed a drunk guy,
junk.
I was coming at him.
He punched him.
I guess I'm,
I don't know the whole story,
but that shit happens all the time.
I've seen guys and it's not about the punch though.
It's about when they hit their head getting hit by the world.
Think about that thing of the world just drop on your head.
That's what it's like.
Your body mass bouncing off a completely,
especially concrete.
There's no gift.
So your head just cook clock.
It sounds horrible.
Why listen to someone's head bounced off concrete is one of the scariest fucking
sounds.
Oh,
it's horrible.
Even if you do it to somebody and you wanted to hurt them,
when you hear their head bounced off concrete,
you're like,
oh shit.
Like that's not as simple as like you punched them,
you punched them and then you know whatever.
They weigh 190 pounds with all the mass of grass,
all their mass and gravity pulling them towards the ground with nothing slowing
it down.
But meat and head bang bone I shoulder.
That reminds me when I was 10 years old,
I was sitting on the curb,
and this is the first time I saw death in real life from a head injury.
I was sitting with my friend on the curb and a guy was driving a motorcycle and
he was speeding up and down the street and right on iris would,
and Houston,
Texas,
he's flying down a car,
pulls out and he hits it.
Back then they didn't wear helmets,
so he literally flew up in the air and landed about 20 feet from us.
His head hit first and exploded like a watermelon.
And this is like,
I was 10 years old watching this.
So the next morning,
you know,
the police come,
my parents get me to tell me,
don't look at it.
I go out there the next day,
it's just blessed stains everywhere and his wife is picking up his hair that's
stuck to the concrete.
And I remember it so vividly.
I was next door neighbor was Eric and we were sitting on the curb watching this
lady pick up her husband's hair that was stuck in,
and that's the first time I ever saw death.
And it was,
and it was a gnarly death too.
It was like that facing death stuff.
Like it was bad.
It was bad.
They never rode a motorcycle because of that.
Yeah.
There's,
there's not a lot of reasons to ride a motorcycle other than it's awesome.
Yeah.
Just fuck fucking,
I took a motorcycle safety classes and then two of my friends,
uh,
wiped out.
One of them got hit by a car and one of them fell,
uh,
going around a corner and fucked his shoulder up.
I,
uh,
after that accident,
probably about six years later,
you know,
in three wheelers with big,
yeah.
And my friend,
same friend that was on the curb,
we were f three Whelan and,
and where I grew up there as bunch of ditches.
So we're going and he thought he could go down in the ditch and come up the
other side,
but I think he forgot that it's flat on the bottom of real ditches.
So literally we're going and we hit the bottom and I flew up in literally half
my face was like just wrecked.
I was in the hospital and,
and we didn't have helmets and cause we're young and dumb and just wanted to
like stupid,
stupid,
stupid please.
Elysian like when you let boys just wander around,
it's never good.
It's never did dumb shit that they do that they think is okay,
let's try this.
Hey take those fireworks and stick them in this tree.
This old rotted don't tree,
let's blew up.
And the problem is I think,
I think today parents,
at least we know more,
I feel we tell,
but like our parents,
at least my parents,
they didn't really give me guidance.
You know,
they were kind of like,
hey,
figure it out on your own mind to yeah.
And that was that generation though.
They,
yeah,
like my parents is the parents that didn't tell you they loved me till I was 29
and I forced him to go.
Wow.
That's different.
Yeah.
My parents taught me to love her all the time.
My parents were hippies.
Oh my stepdad are hippies.
I don't know.
Maybe it was in a good way.
In a good way.
It really nice people.
Yeah.
Yeah man that they didn't tell me Shit though.
Like what to do something.
Why your grades so bad and like,
oh what the fuck do I do?
Tell him it's on someone's toes that they've learnt man.
You know like when you have like if you have a full time job and the wife has a
full time job and you're raising children,
man,
how much time does that really leave?
I mean I don't get home until six seven like when do you get out of work at five
by the time you get home the kids have been home from school for three hours
already exhausted.
They just want to eat and go to sleep.
Like you're not learning anything about each other for like five days a week.
Well,
I,
that's my,
my mom worked for my dad so I got to see my mom a lot.
But it was a type of relationship where when I was growing up,
my mom's Asian,
my dad's black,
I guess there wasn't that,
hey,
we love you.
I mean I knew they loved me,
but they didn't ever say that's it.
And the only reason they said it is because I was dating a girl at the time and
they use the I love you think all the time.
And I thought that was very strange because I've never heard people just say it
all the,
Hey,
I love you.
I love you,
So I called my dad and I was like,
Hey,
I love you.
And he goes,
any hung up?
Like literally he got like kind of like,
he was just like,
okay,
you know,
it was like,
all right,
cool.
And then he hung up and then now after I got married and have a kid,
now we say,
I love
you all the time.
You know,
so,
cause I don't want my son to grow up with no,
I love yous.
Yeah.
It's just this is different time for them,
man.
It was a different time.
It's a foolish insecurity because if you say you love,
you say I love you to someone.
Um,
either they love you back and it feels great or they don't and you don't hang
out with them anymore.
I to say I love you to somebody.
Like I reserve it for people that I love and usually they love you too.
Yes.
You're,
there's something wrong with your wiring.
This,
you're looking at it wrong,
you know?
Yeah.
I know that's never happened to me,
Joe.
Where I told somebody I loved them and they said nothing back.
It can happen due dude's clam up sometimes.
Tell friend you love them.
Hey,
I love you man.
They go,
yikes.
This is not for me wearing,
this is too weird,
man.
I grew up in Nebraska,
but I think it's also a young dude thing too.
When you're young,
you're macho.
You don't want to say I love you too.
Another dude now sure.
When you get older,
like actually if you live in,
in Nebraska.
I'm just kidding.
Nebraska.
Don't get uptight.
Somebody sent me a box in Nebraska tee shirts.
Cornhusker once like,
listen son,
I ain't wearing that.
My,
my wife's father is from Nebraska.
Is He?
Yeah.
Well there you go.
Yeah,
that's a good time.
It's good to spot as any oil spots.
It used to suck.
They don't suck as much anymore.
Now.
I mean the Internet really,
I mean,
what's there to do in Nebraska?
Let's be serious.
Like pheasant hunt,
I think it's a good pheasant hunting spot.
Okay.
They've got the corn huskers,
they got corn.
If you just want to be alone,
start,
start a cult.
I think it's a good spot.
Start out.
Great.
Yeah.
If you want to start a cult though,
you got to live in an attractive climate.
You know?
I think that's why,
uh,
that's why that place in Arizona that everybody goes to Scottsdale.
No,
no,
no.
The other one sit down on that one.
That's the one where all the cult leaders go down.
How do you explain Waco then?
That's the armpit of Texas.
Let's split.
It isn't,
he gets a Dallas pretty quick from Waco recruit.
You got Dallas for grouse ranch out in Waco.
Go check out a cowboys game.
Come back after recruit bar.
Yeah.
Nah,
I couldn't.
This whole coping thing,
I don't get it.
So don't as a weird one.
Right?
Because it's all like crystals and healers.
It's all people look at it be spiritual that they've given up on on traditional
religion,
but they seem to need that sort of vibe and so they,
they get into like spiritual stuff and channelers and he learns.
Have you got of that stuff?
I knew it all day long.
All right.
Oh one all about channeling,
bro.
That's my thing.
I mean it channeling.
Yeah,
right.
I mean,
no,
no.
I think we,
I really do believe,
and I've,
I've been believing this more and more lately though,
that our understanding of what our memory is is a very limited,
and that the reason why people are scared of things,
some things is probably because there's some sort of genetic memory of someone
that they knew.
Like,
I bet your
will have somehow or another that knowledge of that motorcycle accident and that
fee.
There's,
I think shit like that goes through DNA do.
Yeah,
I do.
I think that's why kids are scared of monsters.
You know why his kids?
Scared of monsters?
Why aren't they scared of bullets or fires or you know,
like why?
Why aren't they're screaming?
They're,
they're scared of something that I was scared of growing up.
No,
there's animals used to eat people.
Yeah.
That's what I think.
I think monster's represent like Jaguars and shit.
Like you're going through the John and tried to get some water and you get
jacked.
That's our ancestors.
All of our ancestors,
every single human being on this planet came from Africa.
All of us.
100% of us.
Everyone.
Absolutely.
Jen,
black,
white.
All of us got eaten.
All of our ancestors in our DNA.
It's wired.
This cats out there.
What are you afraid of?
Monsters in the dark.
Those are cats,
man.
We got jacked by cats like all the time.
Yeah.
So that's why everybody's scared of things under the bed.
What's in the closet?
They're hiding their cats.
Big Cats looking to get you.
I don't know about that.
This was very scary for a moment,
but I don't believe in that.
But why do you think that animals have instincts,
right?
Like here's a perfect example.
We have instincts,
right?
But what kind of instincts?
Animals have weird instincts.
Like they all sniff each other's assholes.
They all piss on spots where other animals did.
They don't.
Nobody had to teach.
My dog had to do that.
My dog,
I got him when he was six weeks old and I've had him for two and a half years.
That motherfucker will sniff something and he sees somebody peed on it.
He pees on it.
But he learned that from his,
he didn't learn that from nobody.
No.
He learned that from his dog.
People.
What's it like when you came over here?
He didn't know Jack Shit.
So he says,
no,
I think it's in his DNA.
Okay.
Yeah,
I get that.
But what is the DNA like?
Doesn't your DNA carries some traces of information onto your own children?
Like what I notice in my children,
they share certain weird traits that I have that I don't like,
like a obsessive compulsive traits that I don't think they see because I don't
really bring that home.
Like especially like the workout stuff and like some,
some things that I really get kind of psychotic about martial arts stuff.
My middle daughter has that in a crazy way and I'm like,
Oh okay this is me.
If I was a girl.
Okay.
Like if I was a little girl,
this is me.
Like what is it?
So is this my memory that's in her or is it,
do I have like some weird obsessive Jean I,
which is it?
It is the DNA because I see my son,
he's only two,
he just turned two.
But he makes facial expressions and looks like he does certain looks that I do
and,
and my wife goes,
he's acting like you right now.
You think he's acting like you cause he sees you act like that or is he acting
like,
cause he knows in his head that that's how he's wired like that.
Because when I watched it,
he doesn't like a lot of this
stuff.
He does.
I don't eat,
I don't even do,
he just does like my mom or come over and she'll wash them.
She go,
he knows.
He's just like you when you were this age and it's so weird.
Yeah,
it's in the DNA.
It's in something,
right.
Whatever it is.
Whether it's in cellular memory,
DNA,
some sort of genetic information gets passed on,
but the parents,
the child,
you could say that about athletics though.
Like if you get too,
that's a little different though,
but it's in the DNA.
Yeah,
it isn't the DNA,
but it's not an ethereal thing like a thought.
You know what I mean?
Like so like here's one of 50 of phobia or Arachnophobia,
fear of snakes or spiders.
Those.
Have you ever seen anybody who has that?
Well,
you are on fear factor with me.
Oh my God.
That was the worst.
He'd say you were.
You made it out,
Bro.
Laces.
No.
Do you remember in one episode?
One I was the pilot episode of fear billing episode.
And that's where I met you for the first six.
Can you believe 16 what?
2001 yeah.
What does that,
it's 1819 years ago we met because that was,
that was right after nine 11 yes.
Yeah,
right after it.
And they flew us down and the first time I met you,
it was that saddle ranch and you're like,
welcome this dude.
Oh Man.
Okay.
This is later.
Way later when we did the new season of it in like 2011 yeah.
You tried to get me to eat that spider.
Yeah,
that's when I was acting like a spad bro.
Dude.
Dude,
that's not a normal thing.
And you just chomped it like a chance.
So this whole scene,
I'm acting like a little bee.
Oh,
answers.
Little,
little fearful.
You had each sheeps eyebrow eyeball stone,
which had to eat,
dude.
Now those were disgusting.
Did you eat,
eat it?
Because I felt bad for you guys.
That was before I had hardened.
I'd been hardened to the world.
Cause you guys were episode one,
season one and it didn't seem right for me that you guys would have to eat these
things and I didn't need it.
So I said,
if you guys eat it,
I'll eat it too.
But they didn't show it like they wouldn't show it on television that I ate it
because they didn't,
they,
they didn't want it to look too easy.
Yeah.
So weird.
Oh my God.
I remember biting down into it and it kind of like burst and then that retina,
then you had to just shop too.
Yeah.
You had to chew on that rent and we had to eat three of them.
They weren't good.
No,
they were horrible.
But you know,
it was surprisingly mild.
I ate a roach.
I'm not,
not bragging too much,
just a roach.
If not,
it doesn't taste like much.
Like why don't you eat a roach?
Is that part of the show?
It was a celebrity fear factor.
There was a young lady who was scared to eat a roach and uh,
she was going to get eliminated from the show.
And so I said,
listen,
I'll make you a deal.
I'll,
if you do it,
I'll do it.
And she's like,
you will.
I go,
yeah,
I will.
And she wouldn't do it.
So she made a deal like,
like three worms.
She decided I'll eat three warm,
like we'd negotiated into three moms.
And so then I ate a row.
I remember when I was on that show,
the question they would ask you in the survey is,
what's your fear of dying?
And I wrote down dying on the water because that would be my biggest fear is
dying underwater.
And so our last stunt was when they dumped us on a water and my friends still
send me screenshots of that because that's when I had long hair and I put a
bunch of gel in it and they dumped me under the tank.
And literally it looked like a squid shoot.
You,
if you could Google it,
Google Michael,
yo a fear of fat.
And it's,
my friends will just screenshot that and they still play that to this day.
They still play that episode of fear factor.
All of them,
they play him on.
Um,
different like tru TV or something like that.
One of those I remember shows,
I remember when we were talking,
I'll go,
cause you were what show were you on at that time?
Radio.
You were on news radio.
That was a couple of years earlier.
Hey you are look at that.
What happened?
Yeah.
And okay so that's the Shipibo Michael Yo
cheap cibo so at the Ed at the end I go to Joe and I go,
hey man,
I can't do the last dot.
Look at that.
I can't.
Okay so this is you talking to me.
Cause Joe goes,
Joe goes,
hey,
I go Joe,
I'm not going to be able to make it through this whole stunt.
I can't hold my breath for that long.
And you go,
oh just make it look great for the camera.
So when I,
I was going to try to talk you into it,
but I wasn't good enough at it then I did.
I had to figure out how to talk people into it.
Cause I know there's some people that would just psyching themselves out yet in
the smoker one our episode,
the guy that we thought that it was going to lose no oxygen.
Yeah,
it's fucking system.
He's used to having no oxygen and that's when they cast it fear factor off of
personality and then it just became a hot fast.
Like if you're a sexy,
it was also um,
you know,
they kept ramping up the difficulty of stuff like the last season scared the
shit out of me when they were launching a car through a moving train and an
explosion happens when the car,
it looks like what you're going to kill somebody.
And when I came up to your,
uh,
I think it was the last season y'all were doing something with a donkey Dong
touchy come canceled.
Yes,
yes.
I remember showing up.
It just is coming here.
You know,
like what was so crazy,
everybody was going to quit when I showed up that day and they brought the paper
into my trailer and he told me what it was going to be.
I don't think I knew about that one before.
Some of them I had known about,
knew about before,
but I don't think I knew about that one.
Oh,
I think when they brought that in I had no idea.
And I was like,
you can't do this.
I'm like,
no one's gonna do it.
First of all,
they're all going to quit.
But what was hilarious is I'm sitting there next to you watching them drink this
up.
We're just lacking.
How about an intern had a drink it an intern had drinking.
I think they only got like $100 what for what?
It was like part of the is that they would have to test it when,
when they would like say here's some fear factor info.
So like say if you had to eat like a kidneys,
right?
How many,
how many kidneys can someone eat in a minute?
You know,
like how much,
how much meat can you actually like consistent gusting,
dried meat,
can you consume?
And so what we had was certain interns,
they would volunteer for it and they would get like an extra hundred and
something dollars.
And I would always give him money to I,
it was giving me a couple hundred bucks on top of it,
but they would,
they would eat whatever the fuck it was and they would determine,
all right,
well Mike usually can put it down like,
like,
like no one.
And if he could only get through three and then some other producers would come
and go,
fuck this.
We're being pussies.
Making me for like for you guys are crazy.
And this was like the debate.
The debate on the set would be like how much blood they drink one gallon,
one gallon of blood.
Like they never drank blood,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like how many horse Dicks,
they never had a horse dick,
but they did eat like [inaudible] and elk,
Dick's and dear Dick.
But the donkey come was the worse.
Oh yeah.
And I even remember at the shoot you were like,
yeah,
I think the show's over after this.
Like they didn't air it.
I think they didn't get an error occurred in other countries though.
Oh,
did it?
Really?
Yeah.
So he could get it like,
and I think it's like Dutch and so it's like you hear,
you hear us talk in English but then they have Dutch subtitles.
Yeah.
That,
that was,
that was such so stupid.
It's so,
are you surprised how stupid people are to go?
No,
because I think people were like,
look,
it's an experience.
I'm here for the experience.
I'm going to have some fun.
This is crazy.
But when you get to donkey come yet,
you're kind of being rude.
Yeah.
Those folks,
you know,
you got a donkey.
This donkey,
the donkey come is like,
can advantage of their need for fame in a weird way.
No,
you are.
But Hey,
they want to give it,
that's the game.
And I remember you showing it to me first and it was in this large,
a glass container and they,
and it wasn't a little,
they had to drink.
No,
no,
no.
It was,
I have to drink a lot.
Yeah.
It was like the aforementioned Rhino Horn beer mug.
Fucking large chuck.
Yeah.
No,
it's even more offensive on donkeys are,
they're not fertile.
Look at it.
There it is.
Oh,
that's it.
Yes.
So that come is useless.
It's not just come,
but imagine it's like it's,
it's come that could never even be babies.
Okay.
To Mail Shit.
But I remember when y'all used to do stuff,
this is disgusting.
I remember I used to do stunts.
It was actually a delicate,
like people in other countries actually ate it sometimes.
Sometimes.
Yeah.
Like balloon.
So that's not,
that's just being done.
That's just being me.
Okay.
That's no other country is doing that just for fun to keep up on that whole,
uh,
this,
in other countries,
this is considered a delicacy.
Yeah.
He gave up on them long time ago.
You had to push the envelope on that.
Now one of the things that made things gross smell wise was actually really
expensive cheese.
They would go to this,
uh,
expensive was if a former Marjorie,
what do they call them?
One of the call one of those cheese places.
Yeah.
That's like Italian for chief Tomas if for Moseri for machine,
isn't it French too?
Something like that.
Sure.
I'm proud.
Yeah.
Jamie's my,
that's my translation.
They both come from that.
I'm dumb.
So there you go.
But anyway,
this cheese that we would use was disgusting.
It smelled so bad.
But apparently it taste really good if you're into that kind of cheese.
Like Bordain was really into stinky cheese.
Like he would talk to me about it like with passion like that,
just the,
the fucking stinkier the better like disgusting,
smelly cheese and the taste is fantastic.
I'd be like,
wow.
I would think that the smell with what turned you off.
Absolutely.
I don't know.
It's like one of those things where I guess you catch like the right vibe.
Like you go in with the right attitude.
There is no editor.
If it stinks,
fuck that dude [inaudible] cheese.
And they would squeegee it off into a blender,
blend it up with the other stuff,
like worms and shit.
It would make the worms tastes horrific or smell horrific.
Oh,
so you were just messing with their smell sense.
So it can make it seem like it was worse than the room.
I can get worse because it smelled worse.
So it was making more like smell it,
but
people would just start retching
it was,
it's a ridiculous fucking thing.
It's a ridiculous thing.
Like to the show was really silly.
No,
but I,
I love that these people wanted to be famous too,
Bro.
But I wasn't,
but none of them ended up.
But I knew I was different.
That was different too because how it happened.
I was in Austin,
Texas and there was an ad in the paper that goes,
hey,
have you ever done anything adventurous?
And I was like,
no,
let me go in for this.
Cathy.
I was a radio DJ out there and um,
at this radio station.
So I go in and then Mikey,
uh,
they called them the chimp.
He was the casting person.
And literally two weeks later,
three weeks later,
I'm in Hollywood shooting this thing.
And then I meet you.
And then I remember going up to you,
cause I was in awe.
It was the first time in a Hollywood,
I'll go and I knew you from news,
right?
And I was like,
how do you do it?
And you got to just fucking be yourself.
You can be successful.
And that's what you're doing right now.
Just fucking being yourself.
This is what you're doing too.
We're where we're trying.
We tried this and I did listen,
let ridiculous piece of advice.
Just be yourself.
Do whatever you do.
Don't improve
right now forever.
Good luck.
Just be yourself.
That's all you need,
Bro.
That's it.
Just believe in your dreams and make a vision board.
I was just trying to get me out of the space.
Oh,
just be you.
All right.
But that is the right advice.
Especially if you want to be an entertainer.
If you can figure out how to be yourself as long as yourself is actually
something interesting and if it's not working yourself.
Yeah.
And then you even said that about acting.
He's like,
I remember specifically say,
Oh,
act is not hard.
It's just you yourself and you play that emotion.
And I was like,
oh,
that sounds easy.
You like if the ace in comparison to stand up in some ways,
but this is not like a disrespect,
like the kind of shit that like Daniel,
late Daniel Day Lewis and Leonardo Dicaprio.
Yeah.
When they,
when they get into a fucking roll and you're like God damn that guy just own
that shit.
Like they get into what I'm talking about is like sitcoms,
Sitcom acting.
Yeah.
Sitcom Act.
And they were hiring you to be at that time 100%.
So it was a,
a slightly dumbed down version of me who was into slightly more conspiracy
theories,
didn't me when I was on news radio.
That's how it was.
It was basically me,
like they wrote a lot of that conspiracy shit in after I'd talked to them about
like JFK and fucking,
you know,
Ufo shows and stuff.
You believe in Ufos.
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
Really?
Yeah.
See I believe in,
there's other other life forms out there,
but I don't think they're coming here.
They might think they might.
Well why not think it,
but just,
here's,
here's one thing.
I do believe most people are full of shit when it comes to like most of their
stories,
like it's,
it's hard to find a person that could just tell you what happened based on what
they really remember.
People want to jazz things up and they will want to add salt and pepper.
They just sex with me.
They don't,
they don't necessarily tell you the truth.
They tell you what they think is going to be an engaging story that kind of
represents the truth.
Maybe.
Especially when it's a weird thing like you saw something in the sky.
What did you really see?
How long did you look at it for?
How many seconds was it?
Well,
I mean,
here's the problem I have with Ufo and I believe there are Ufo shows,
but I don't think they're coming here.
What that means that would you say that because that means their tech,
first of all,
if they're coming here,
that means their technology is far way more advanced than ours.
Right?
So why would they care if people saw them?
They would show up.
If I was an alien and I was that far ahead of us,
I would lay in that bitch right in the middle of time square and be like,
what we are here?
Why would you do that?
But why would I,
why am I helping in fields where nobody can see us?
Are you aware of how we treat uncontacted tribes?
He,
yes,
to a point to point,
but what I'm saying is if you're that far advanced,
they know if they're coming here,
they know they're,
they're way smarter than that because they've traveled here and we don't even
know other from far distances.
We can't even imagine and they're here.
They don't have to hide.
It's just like they do it because they have to hide or do you think maybe they
do it because we can't handle it because we can't handle it?
Why would they care if we could handle it or not?
Because here's the problem.
When ever any civilization has ever encountered a civilization superior
to them,
the results have always been catastrophic.
Every single time.
Every time Europeans have invaded North America.
Every time the Spanish visited the Mexicans,
every time that this has happened,
it's been a disaster.
And this is human beings.
If there was something that came down here from another planet was so
unbelievably sophisticated that they could travel through vast distances in
space and had insurmountable,
impossible technology that we would look to it for all of our answers.
It would become our new daddy.
It would completely disrupt all of our governments.
It would disrupt all of our religions.
It would disrupt every single belief system we have and people would fall apart.
They wouldn't know what to do.
Psychologically,
it would be devastating.
Look,
I'm not a doctor,
but I'm not a sack.
I psychologist,
but I know most people would not be able to handle it.
I understand that,
but why would they care?
Because that's my whole point.
Because why would they care about,
cause it would be affecting our culture and they wouldn't care.
But why wouldn't they care?
Well,
why would they care?
We care about animals,
Bro.
There's a reasonable,
we have wildlife protection agencies.
We have that because we care about animals and animals don't even know were a
thing.
If you're a deer living in the forest,
you're two years old.
You might not have ever even seen a person.
You don't even know what the fuck we are,
but we're trying to keep those deer alive.
We spend billions of dollars every year protecting them.
We do that because we care about wildlife.
If we cared about a rare monkey that we found in Indonesia,
in the forest,
I'm strange monkey.
We would do whatever we could to make sure that that monkeys populations
thrived.
If there was a way to help them.
I mean,
that's one of the reasons why zoos exist.
They take rare animals,
they try to breed them in captivity,
but we're also sharing the same earth.
Well then maybe they look at the universe that way and maybe look at,
okay,
nuclear civilizations like our civilization,
I mean our civilizations a very dangerous one because we're a bunch of semi
hairless monkeys with nuclear weapons.
I mean,
we're fucking nuts,
bro.
Oh yeah.
We're obsessed with sex,
with jack off to our phones where we're taking pills to keep our dick hard.
We're all on speed mean we all have ab.
These are we're at and we lie.
We lie about shit.
We lie about things that people did to us.
We pretend people think did worse things.
We pretend that we didn't do things to people.
We lie about stealing,
we lie about money,
we lie about all kinds of things.
I mean people are so,
so you're thinking,
you're thinking aliens are thinking about all that before they come down.
Of course they would.
Why wouldn't I?
Why wouldn't,
I guess I'm coming from a human point of view where we don't give a shit about
anything and there's a thing that's not true.
We do give a shit about things.
That's why when you go to the Galapagos Islands,
you're not allowed to take your shoes,
but you walked around Los Angeles and walk around the Galapagos Island because
people have done that and they've gotten seeds from their shoes stuck in the
sand over there and the ground over there.
And then new plants grow that are invasive species.
They were worried about ecosystems that we really are.
That's why I humans,
that's where we're worried about invasive species.
When new
species get introduced to new ecosystems,
it's like we were just talking about this yesterday,
a everglades,
my people are doing whatever the fuck they can to get the pythons and the
African hoons.
These assholes have released pythons and there's a real fucking redneck Jurassic
park going on in the middle of Florida.
Yeah.
You know,
we care.
I lived in Miami man,
and at the time I lived in Miami.
Talk about like you did radio out there,
right?
Yeah.
Why 100 miles after fear factor after fear factors.
It lay into me that big gig after it was after I was off for your back there.
Well,
radio was radio back though.
Oh yeah,
it's real.
It was,
it was like huge man.
Uh,
but I remember they had these lakes and if you go back like 10 years ago and
look up Florida,
people were just jogging around lakes getting snatched by alligators,
like just alligators did not give a damn that it would just snatch and people
and I was like,
why are people jogging?
Like
really?
I like stopped jogging.
Well definitely don't jog near the water.
No.
And that's the thing.
I believe like eight people within six months got snatched.
Just jogging my real oh,
100%.
Probably about eight to 10 years ago.
Just jogging.
I didn't know that,
that there was that many deaths ever from Alec.
Oh yeah.
They were getting snatched.
One of my favorite ones was a guy who was running from the cops near Miami and
uh,
he was in a stolen car,
parked his car on a bridge,
jumped off the bridge and landed on an alligator.
Alligator jacked him in front of the cops and they were just sitting there
going,
oh,
well there you go.
Guilty.
Imagine jumps off the bridge,
splash.
[inaudible] that would be this.
Oh my God,
Dude.
Oh,
that guy didn't even notice.
No last minute.
No,
that's what I'm saying.
Like that happens in Florida at that time.
That is so crazy.
That is such a big thing that eats deer and shit.
Look at,
it opens its mouth on him.
Let me,
it tries to get away from people.
Well,
what's interesting to do,
didn't even speed up like I'm just going off.
Probably really tired.
He was an for a while to fuck these things,
man.
Fuck these things.
But the craziest thing is when we were showing it yesterday that pythons eat
them alligators,
whole Jude one,
python eight this fucking big ass alligator and it blew its body apart.
Apparently another aligator came along while it had it in its body and tried to
eat the python.
And so then it was like this disaster of a python with an alligator inside of it
with no head.
Oh yeah man.
But the whole thing was that this python at eight the alligator,
and then once they eat it,
they can't move because they got a fucking 900 pound alligator.
But she loved that Shit.
I can't take it out.
I know you do.
You do have a problem with,
um,
I just,
I get some animals eating other animals.
Like I think it's important to recognize that we're,
we're,
we're very insulated from what the fuck is going on by cities and that in houses
and
cities and even towns,
even if you have a town,
it's rare that a fucking wild Predator makes its way into your town.
But man,
that's the whole rest of the world.
That's the whole world,
including the ocean.
Everywhere is all just predators and prey.
Predators and prey.
We figured out a way to insult,
but,
but in insulation,
the problem is when we're isolated from it,
we neglected as an aspect of nature.
We,
we put it in some weird boggling,
oh my God,
this is weird.
No,
that's not weird.
That's normal.
That's normal life.
Normal life is big things.
Eating little things and you don't respect it.
Got It.
Really don't respect it when you don't see it.
Like,
my parents want to go to Africa on a safari.
I'm like,
man,
you can have that.
Yeah,
I would go if I got one of them like Jurassic Park mobiles that they have with
the tall
roll around on the face.
We can you see that you see these people who are just in regular jeeps,
jeeps where alliance just walking around.
I was like,
how dumb are you?
And most of the time nothing happens.
No most,
most of it.
But it could be one or two times where if you're in it until years ago,
a woman who worked on game of Thrones,
she was there on vacation and she got pulled out of her fucking cuss.
Right?
She rolled down the window to take a picture and the cat came and snatched her
out of the car.
But don't you think people kind of like that deserve it?
Like people that roll down windows and not safer?
Like that's like people jumping in the pit at the zoo the other day.
Well the a Selfie,
the roll down the windows thing I think is really just,
it's what we're talking about that you're not around it enough so you don't
understand what it is.
But do you have to be around it to know it?
Hey,
these are wild animals and things.
They can get away with shit if they've never had anything happen to them.
Like if they've never been punched.
Oh,
this is,
this is a cheetah.
Cheetah's are actually not.
They're actually very curious and then not dangerous to people.
So this dude has no idea this thing is in his backseat.
No,
he's filming it.
Oh,
That's why he's not moving.
I think so man.
I think the move is don't move.
You don't want to scare them.
You definitely don't want to go,
hey man,
I'm fucked.
Fuck you.
Don't want to do that and have a fucking rip your face off.
They don't have flaws.
They don't have claws like a cat does.
They're more like a dog.
Yeah.
You know,
there are a weird animal.
They're like a weird cat dog thing.
You know,
there's super,
super fast.
Like I've never seen one run in real life,
but apparently people who I know that I've seen it say,
you can't believe how fast it is.
You know,
one thing that blew me away,
I was reading about it,
that hippopotamuses kill more people a year than all the animals combined.
All of them all love them.
Yeah.
All of them.
And it's just like people just like don't respect hippopotamus is,
and they're fast and they're strong and they'll rip you apart.
They're like a giant pig.
Yeah.
During the pig family cousin to a pig or some shit.
And they're vegetarians.
Yeah.
Like they're just killing people.
Estimated 500 people per year.
And that guy,
they killed 500 a year.
They're aggressive and they're very sharp teeth.
And not only that man,
people think there's a 750 kilograms.
What?
What is that dude
pizza that in pounds.
That's more than 5,000 pounds.
Yeah,
2.2 times that.
So.
Oh my God,
that's,
well,
people don't respect because they think they're slow to,
so when they see them,
I think they run like 24 25 miles per hour.
Wear like a a hundred a person that runs a hundred yard dash in the Olympics,
I think average around like 29 to 30 miles per hour.
No hippos.
Oh,
19 miles.
So that's still fast.
Yeah.
You're barely getting away.
Well that's me.
I probably can't run 90 miles an hour.
I know I could.
I'll probably get eaten.
Fuck.
Can you imagine?
You're like 20 yards away from this thing and you're like,
ah,
it's not going to be,
and then it just runs up on you.
Well,
they save you.
You ever get chased by an alligator too?
The thing is to Juke them,
go left and go right.
I know that pictures terrifying me.
Scares the shit out of me.
That scares the shit out of me.
I mean,
look at that guy.
He's,
he's,
he's launching himself in the air trying to get away from,
look at that.
Yeah.
They chase after boats in the water.
They swim fast.
Yeah.
They're trying to fuck you up,
man.
That tried to fuck you.
500 people a year,
dude.
Hippos husband sees hippo bite out wife's heart whites.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
he mad.
You wife falls into the water and that you see the hippo rip open the rib cage.
Ah,
I would be a hippo punisher.
I would go back to Africa every year and kill it.
Every one,
every one of them.
I'd be responsible for hippo extinction.
They'd be like,
you can't do that.
I'm like,
but I'm going to
stop me.
I'm killing all the hippos.
Why not?
I'm killing all the snakes for if everybody and anyone knew got killed the first
day that something gets killed by a fucking python in Florida.
When a human gets jacked,
we should send in the marines just as go through the fucking swamp and killed
them all.
Just like they're the enemy.
You just get a giant line of human beings go through and kill those fucking
serpents.
They're in the Bible.
Okay.
During the Bible,
snakes elite,
your baby,
they will go through them all.
I mean,
are those get cocky with monsters living in your fucking neighborhood?
Is there any purpose of them though?
Yeah,
they kill rats,
but the problem is in that area,
it's not established for them.
So there was this rich ecosystem of mammals and reptiles talking about
everglades right now.
It used to be there was some snakes like cotton mouth and stuff like that and
there was alligators,
but then there was like marsh hairs and raccoons and skunks.
God,
they're all gone.
This is gone.
There's nothing left.
There's just anacondas then pythons and Nile crocodiles.
Now if this guy,
that's another one eating a fucking,
well,
let me ask you this alligator and be honest with me.
If,
if that guy got eaten like a guy that actually tracks it was reptiles.
Do you feel sorry for like if you putting yourself in harm's way?
Yeah,
because I want that guy to be out there to kill those goddamn monsters.
If you ever look into an eye of a snake and you go,
oh,
this thing doesn't give a fuck about anybody.
It's like it doesn't.
I was watching this video of a crab and it's a crowd,
a mother crab to sitting there eating its babies.
It had like thousands of babies all around it that had just hatched like a
couple of weeks ago and it's just sitting there eating it's babies and I'm like,
yeah,
fuck you.
No,
you're going in the boiling water and I'm going to crack you open.
I heard him scream when they go into a cream.
Oh yeah.
I don't think they're really screaming.
I think it's probably air escaping their body.
Look at this.
Can you look at her?
She's eating her kids.
This is crazy.
I was,
I was at a friend's house and they caught crabs and they were throwing it and I
think they scream,
man.
I think it's like,
no,
I really didn't have vocal cords.
This is a,
what does,
this is video Jamie for people to just listen.
It says a monster.
Red Crab eats babies.
The dark side of nature.
Yeah,
she's an asshole.
They scream,
they make a noise.
When you put them in a hot boiling pot of water,
what is the bottom of her?
She's just got a charcoal briquette stuck under her.
Doesn't that look so like one of them,
when a baby's hand from the Gaelic Games,
they come right back out.
So gross.
She's such an asshole.
She was sitting there eating their kids like that.
Anybody would give a fuck about crabs.
Oh well I,
it's not going to want them to go extinct,
but that's one animal that we in our house kill ourselves and no one has a
problem with it.
It's like if they brought home a rabbit and you gotta to throw it in the water,
like fatal attraction.
If like that was the only way to keep,
nobody would eat ram.
No,
no,
no.
And we throw them in like a lie,
a lie.
I'm telling you,
they're in the water that most of the time,
most people don't even bother taking off the lobsters.
Lobsters,
we do not give a shit about apps.
You
get in there,
get in here.
You fucking bug
was crazy is uh,
the whole,
this whole animal kingdom thing.
But one thing that scares me that you were doing when I walked in his playing
these fucking shooter games to that game is a real problem.
Jamie and I have been going to war for the last what,
two months and this died like two months ago.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm in full blown addiction mode now.
What is the threat like?
Aye.
What's the thrill?
Yes.
Do you see us?
We're all sweating and adrenaline.
You guys know about great ass time.
I walked in,
it looked like I just finished working out.
It was like crazy.
Amy and I were going to war.
We go to war.
We talk a lot of shit too.
I tried.
It's fun.
We kills me.
Talk Shit to me.
It's rough.
You're like,
God damn it.
He got me fuckers.
Is that a game where people can go online and play with you to,
no,
we don't have people.
We jump on line.
This is the game.
This is it.
Yeah,
dude,
it is a fun ass fucking game.
It's called quake champions and people right now listening and going,
God damn it.
He's talking about it that way again.
But me and Jamie had been,
um,
and and Jeff are there.
Employee had been playing this.
Fucking,
see this isn't bad because they're like characters.
Like I was playing one where it's like human beings and when you shoot somebody,
like I got scared when you get scared to go into the next room because you're
really that nervous,
like it's freaks me out.
These shooter games,
a too realistic,
I grew up with frogger dude.
This is like,
you're always in like some sort of a castle and the people that you're shooting
against,
they don't look anything like a person.
They look like some kind of a cartoon character.
But the graphics are sensational.
But more importantly like the game play is very precise.
And um,
you,
you have to have like real hand eye coordination and skills.
Like you learn things like tactics,
you learn how to move around maps,
you learn how to control resources.
Controlling resources is giant.
Like that thing that guy just picked up that's like 175 health and you want to
get all the armor that you possibly can.
Then you also want to be like clever about weapons choices cause you're always
engaging at different distances.
Different kinds of fights you like.
Sometimes you're stuck in like a car door and sometimes you know you're,
you're in an area where they can't shoot you,
but you can shoot them if you use the right weapon.
Man,
you need to bring it back to old school.
A,
that one red button that I ran,
that one red button did everything on the joystick.
You never killed a guy with a rail gun.
Once you kill a guy with a real gun,
you'll understand.
I don't want to kill a guy with a real person.
Yeah,
he's laughing while you do it.
If he jumps at me and I shoot him in there with a rail gun,
we both laugh.
Like he shot me in the face the other day with a rocket and I was like,
dude,
in the Mug,
I was like in the Mug,
like right in my face and I exploded.
Like my whole spring just becomes a big red splatter.
I'm like,
fuck,
it's fun.
I can't handle it,
man.
It's too much for me.
I'm a Wa the older I get,
I'm just a puss man.
I need to man.
Up.
I used to be so aggressive.
Big Dude,
you're strong.
That's why nobody messes with me.
Oh,
so they leave you alone.
That's mostly because of it.
No,
it's like,
um,
like you,
you like fight and all that stuff.
Like I can't even,
like if somebody punched me in the face today,
I don't know.
How would react?
Like,
I don't know.
I used to be a bouncer at clubs.
I played college football.
Like I was a tough dude.
Now African apart to can to get you to the gym.
No,
no,
no.
I'm in shape.
But I mean like a fight gym.
No.
Why no notified a little bit?
No,
not to fight people.
Well why do you so you don't worry about it?
I never worry about it.
Okay,
well then don't worry about it.
Cause I'm at home at eight 30 sleeping by nine night.
Stand up.
I know.
I saw you at the Improv the other night.
Nobody's gonna jump on stage.
I'm talking about family.
Amen.
You never know people crazy cause anyone to dude jumped up on the WWF and a
attached to who did he attacked?
He attacked bread hiring.
It's like speech.
That's crazy.
But it's gotta be like,
how old is he now?
A stroke survivor.
So fucked up.
And the guy tackled him.
Jesus.
But Joe,
seriously,
you think anybody's gonna jump on stage when you were on you?
Some dude could easily,
you would fucking kill them.
No,
there's a lot of people that can kill me.
You don't get confused that I know a lot of us here all the time.
I get that.
But like I,
I,
I just don't see me doing stand up talking about family and love and a dude
because I hate family and love.
I'm a jump up now that it's not rational.
Right?
A rational person wouldn't do that,
but you're not worried about rational people anyway.
Okay.
So,
so say I started to go to a fight gym.
Like where would I start at?
Like what would I do?
I would say you should try Jujitsu cause it's fun,
it's really good exercise and you'll learn some stuff.
You learn how to do it.
It's a technique based art.
Whereas like say if,
um,
if you like,
there's,
there's guys that I will uh,
do Jujitsu spa and we call rolling.
Okay.
There's guys that I will roll with that are weaker than me,
smaller than me and tapped me every time I wrote with them and I'm a black belt.
Okay.
That's reality.
Like if there's,
there's guys out there that 150 pounds that I could roll with that I know will
tap me virtually every time we roll because their technique is sharper.
They train more often than I am.
They're more focused.
They're more in the groove.
But I also heard you say one of your podcasts,
you've got to watch out who you train with because they might just try to hurt
you.
That's true.
I need,
you got to go to a good school with good ethics because a good school with good
ethics.
They get rid of those guys.
Did you know,
do you know when in studio city I'll do it.
Sure.
I'll get you,
I'll do it.
I want to learn.
There's a good spot,
just a little further than that and Tarzana.
Okay.
Machado's where I got my black belt.
So John Jacques Machado.
I trained there sometimes and um,
he used to have a place in Malibu but closed down because of the fires.
Um,
but they um,
they have an outstanding gym.
It's like one of the best in the country and it's in that area,
like as far as teaching top notch like,
but there's a lot of really good Jujitsu schools now.
It's not like I'm like when I started in 96,
it was hard to find a good gym.
There was only like five of them in all of California.
Right.
Or because it was just starting out.
It's like 93 is when Jujitsu sort of emerged in the public consciousness because
of the UFC.
And then there's the gym started like popping up,
popping up.
But I was really lucky.
There was like Hixon Gracie's,
which is where I took my first class and then Carlson Gracie's,
I thought they were like the same and the other one was closer.
So I just switched to Carlson's.
I didn't know shit.
You know,
it was a white belt,
but,
and then there was a Machado's and then like a couple other places.
How long does it take you to get to a black belt?
Like for you?
Some guy,
it took me a long time.
I was a brown belt for eight years,
but it was just because I wasn't training as much as I should have.
Like they,
you don't,
they don't give them away.
Like you have to be a real black belt.
But there's,
who decides what is somebody just watched instructors and you do know,
everyone knows.
It's like,
like,
you know when a guy is fucking killing,
like he,
let's take like Theo Vaughan for example,
like Theo,
I love him.
He hit a groove sometime ago,
whether it's two years ago or whatever it was.
And I remember being in the of the store and I was like,
dude,
this motherfucker's on fire.
He started hitting that groove.
That where,
where you go and sit down,
you want to watch is set,
you know.
And I think when that happens in Jujitsu,
it's the same kind of thing.
Guys started talking about like,
dude,
Mike has been tapping everybody good.
He's just his,
his Jujitsu so sharp and you're like,
man,
I'm gonna Watch them roll.
And then you watch her Molly like dude that pass the guard pass and then got to
start asking like how often you train and I'm going five days a week now.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm taking two privates pluck and then you know like this guy is on the quest
and you'll see a guy go from white belt to black belt in three years but they
have to be super exceptional,
like really unusual athletes.
Unusual mindset,
unusual discipline.
It can happen most of the time like oh a garden variety estimate is like 10
years is realistic.
White belt to black belt for a regular person.
If you really train hard and you really dedicate yourself but freaks can get
there quicker.
Like Bj Penn,
he wanted the moon Dealz which is the world championships.
After three years of training,
three years of training,
he was a black belt one.
The world child be doing that to Bj's a special guy though.
He's also got legs that are like arms.
He has leg dexterity like no one on the planet.
I got a chicken legs.
That's actually good.
Is it really?
Yeah.
You could cinch up triangles on people with chicken legs.
Yeah,
for real.
And Darcy up people everywhere.
They would just think about it in terms of leverage guys with the longer limbs,
like a hydra.
Gracie is a perfect example.
He's a really tall long guy.
So when the best Jujitsu players ever,
they can do things with those limbs that a shorter person can't do.
In terms of like leverage from joints and stuff like this.
Like there's advantages to every frame.
Like there's a guy like who some are Paul Horez,
the famous like tank of a guide five seven 200 plus pounds and just rips guy's
legs apart and he uses this like short style to dive in on people's legs and get
them in a heel hooks and bars and rip their legs.
He's terrifying and that that style heavily favors being built like a little
tank.
Whereas like that long like you are,
you're a tall long guy,
you would have like good Darce chokes,
good rear nakeds good.
All good arm bars,
good triangles.
You would have lengthened leverage with that length.
Especially with triangles cause long legged guys they can like sometimes a guy
like me with short legs like I'll,
I'll get my legs crossed and I have to adjust a lot to be able to cinch up by
triangle.
Whereas you might be able to just close it up right there.
So you'll have like more opportunities for triangles because of the length of
your limbs.
Have you,
would you have ever been at a point in your,
in your career when you were doing Jujitsu,
where you,
how would you have been in the UFC?
Like at your prime?
Like I have no idea.
I have no idea.
I would have had to have gotten way better.
Like when I was fighting I was just kickboxing.
Yeah,
that was kickboxing.
And first of all,
first it was taekwondo and then went to kickboxing.
And by the time the UFC came around like on the ground,
I was useless.
Okay.
As a straight white belt,
I would get ripped apart every day.
I would go to the gym and if I,
if I tapped anybody,
like if it was like a week went by and I tapped one guy be like,
Woo,
I fucking tapped the guy buddy.
There wasn't that many people doing it,
you know.
So I was going with like,
there was a couple of white belts may be,
and then there was like blue belt and purple belts and Brown belts and those
guys would always tap me.
God.
And so that's just how went for a long time when you're,
you know,
unless you're some kind of freak like some big ass football player or something
like super athlete,
you're probably not going to be behold these guys off there.
They're going to,
they're going to choke you.
And that was it.
True.
You're going to a fight Wesley snipes.
That was way later though,
way later.
That was a brown belt by then and I'd been doing a lot.
I'm for Jude beaten him.
I don't know,
cause we never did ever deserve real martial artist that was a real martial
arts.
But he doesn't know Jujitsu.
The thing that must've been exciting though for super excited because I was
thinking like I knew that he was a real legitimate martial artists.
Like you throw his kicks and punches and it looks really good.
Like he really does know his shit,
but I also know he never fought and there's a big difference between throwing
kicks and I haven't fought in a long time,
but I probably fought a hundred times.
So like I,
I've been,
I've felt that nerves,
I know what that's like.
It'll be crazy as fuck to do it again.
That's what I was thinking.
I May,
it'll probably scare the shit out of me,
but I think I know what to do.
I think I know how to like get in there and start fainting started giving some
movement and see how he reacts.
And then the worst case scenarios,
like I'm like in a scramble,
I'm going to strangle this guy.
Like if this,
if this comes to a scramble because the average person really doesn't know how
helpless they are until the Jujitsu black belt grabs a hold of you and then you
just go,
oh shit.
Like I'm helpless.
Because in a fight you really think like you might be able to punch a guy.
Like maybe if he's friend me and he's swinging at me and I'm swinging at him,
maybe I hit him first.
You really think that,
but this don't swing in.
It's at Jujitsu fight.
If,
if,
if you guys get into some sort of a tussle and that guy grabs you and trips you
in,
boom,
and he's on the ground with his hand on your jacket and knee on your chest,
you're a dead man.
You're a dead man because there's no lucky shot.
A jujitsu black belt is just going to close the distance like that evil fucking
crab and he's just going to see your fucking neck and there's no way you're
going to avoid it and there's no way you're going to survive it.
You're just not going to.
That's why you don't fight people like you can't fight.
You can't fight random people on the streets like when you're young.
That was the thing that you could go to bars.
Like I,
I had some friends that like to throw down when I was younger and I wouldn't do
it.
I was watching but good for you.
Now it's kind of like you got to watch everybody.
You don't know what kind of training
they're doing.
Like everybody is so educated on and it's so big right now.
Well some guy fought off a guy in the subway there was attacking with a knife
with some moves that he learned watching the UFC never even trained before.
He just knew what to do.
Yeah,
he like knew what to do because he'd seen guys like get the mount and drop
ground and pound.
He'd like knew what to do based on watching it.
Yeah.
I think is good.
Like when you mentioned,
I think it's good just to learn so you would feel better about yourself in case
danger comes.
Yeah.
You want to be the person that gets to make the decision.
Here's the thing,
right?
If you don't know how to fight and there's some drunk asshole who does know how
to fight either,
but he might come over and punch you in the face and soccer punch you and he
could hurt you or knock you out in front of your woman.
You want to be the one who gets to decide.
Yeah.
If I'm in a situation and some guy and he's like reasonably close to my size and
he's being an asshole and he's drunk and he gets aggressive with me,
I can decide what to do with him.
Like I can,
it gets,
I don't want to hurt anybody,
but I'm not gonna let you hurt me.
Yeah,
and you get to decide like you don't want a hug.
You've ever had.
We've all seen these seven 11 fucking parking lot fights on youtube or some
asshole in both of them.
Don't know how to fight,
but one guy might fuck that guy up.
You might kick them in the face while he's down.
You don't want to be that guy.
Like you don't want to be in that situation.
It definitely walk away whenever you can.
Always.
We are so opposite because I've only been in one fight in my life.
It was in ninth grade playing basketball.
It was against a dude named Matama.
Like I'll never his name as Matama Drake.
And I threw one punch and I hit him right in the face and he looks at me and
goes,
what's up?
And I was,
no,
we're good.
Oh my God.
You
get away with it.
Oh yeah.
We'd started playing bass.
Thank God.
Like that was it.
Like literally I hit him as hard as I could.
Okay.
I could take a shot and it was just like,
what's up?
I was like,
nothing.
Nothing is up.
So that's the only thing I hit you back.
No.
Wow.
No,
cause I,
uh,
then I started,
you know,
Oh,
you okay.
It's your ball.
Yeah.
That's,
yeah.
I get it,
man.
Not Try to get you back.
I mean,
and then I,
I was,
there was a club in Houston named power tools that I used to the gay bar.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't a be right.
Yeah.
It sounds like one that was hardcore gay bars.
Houston,
the gay bar was called riches at the time,
but I worked at power tools and I was a bouncer so that's when I was like 250
pounds,
you know?
Uh,
you are a lot bigger when I met you.
Oh yeah.
Cause I played college football for Arkansas,
so I played outside linebacker.
So I was just stop lifting weights or do you still with a little bit?
No,
I'm all cardio now because you know like trainers,
any trainer I work with since I got a big frame and I'm like what puts some said
Nah,
I want to stay lean.
Right.
You know,
but it's good for old age too,
man.
You don't want to have back problems.
I'm 44 years old now.
Yeah,
I'm a crazy dude.
Two time flies.
51 see what 55 zero in is so scary when you read stories about people just
dropping dead like around her age.
Luke Perry.
That's what I'm saying.
Mainly my age.
Well they said what?
What is the danger zone is like 45 to 55 with heart failure.
It's like cray and ah man did I beat my body up.
I'm running that bitch until the fucking wheels fall off.
I'm always getting stem cell shots and fucking running hills and lift and
weight.
I still live heavyweights retarded.
Yeah.
Why don't you should say that word?
I said it again.
Trying to get that rid of that word out of my vocabulary.
It just comes out sometimes.
Why?
Why are you still lifting weights?
Like heavy like that?
Like what is this it do for you?
Well,
it does a bunch of things.
First of all,
if you want to train Jujitsu,
it's very good to be strong and makes a big difference.
First of all,
for defense,
especially for defense,
you know like for offense for sure too.
But really you want to be able to defend.
You don't like defending it.
You have to be strong.
But also you just like be in bigger.
It helps.
Yeah,
I like it.
Yeah.
I like being able to pick up things.
I like the physical ability of being true.
I liked being in shape too,
like being on the run for long distances.
I like knowing that I can go rounds on the bag,
like I'll do five hard rounds on the,
so you can run on,
my knees are messed up.
I can't like get on a treadmill and raw.
I can do like I've done the stem and the knee and it's helped out a lot,
but I'm still that dude that's on,
I'm like on the super fortunate.
I'm super fortunate about my knee injuries.
I've had knee injuries,
but um,
my meniscus,
I only had one meniscus scope on my left knee and it wasn't terrible.
Like I was back to full 100% function after that.
And my right knee,
it didn't.
I have a little baby tear that I've got some stem cell shot into,
but I had both of them reconstructed.
Their ACL were replaced,
but I'm no problems.
They work,
they work,
right.
Yeah.
See,
I just need to,
I listened to you and I,
it's like you always taking something and I'm like,
Oh,
I've got to find out what that is and now I just want to get in better shape.
I'm in shape,
but I,
it's when you get older it's just like tough.
It is just,
he is writing it down like you have to do it.
Like do you,
do you keep a daily scan?
Oh Shit.
You have to do it.
No,
I just wake up and go.
I do have,
I wake up,
I work out like a cardio workout and then I do infrared sauna,
which has changed my life.
Changed Your Life,
right?
Every morning I infrared sauna for now.
It's the best.
You sweat all that shit out.
You're like,
you feel great.
Your skin glistens like I think it's actually like changed the game for me.
I have more energy now.
Everything's better.
It's so good for your body.
They did a study that showed a 40% decrease in more cow mortality amongst all
causes.
Heart attack,
stroke,
cancer,
40% decrease with people that were doing the sauna four times a week.
Well,
I will tell you this because the whole thing is everybody wants to feel young
and when you were young,
the thing you did most was sweat.
And I feel like when I sweat it just,
it's a,
it feels,
I don't know,
I just feel good sweating because it reminds me when I played sports,
it reminds me even though I'm not doing on the,
you know,
I sweat a little on the treadmill,
but when I do that infrared,
it makes me feel great.
I think it's,
there's a bunch of shit going on with his dad for sure.
Like it's good to feel good,
like you're sweating,
but there's heat shock proteins.
Your body actually produces anti inflammatory properties.
It's really good for you.
It's really good for joint aches and all kinds of like this.
I used to think of the song as being nonsense.
Like what do you,
what do you fucking lying in a sauna for?
Like what are you doing there?
Just getting hot scorecard.
What kind of a sauna do you do though?
I do a regular song.
Okay.
Super Hot.
Regular Sauna telling you you need to try the infrared.
It's,
yeah,
I mean,
but look,
it's all just about getting your body,
Huh?
Yeah.
Like it's good to try to infrared.
I'm sure.
I'm sure it works great.
But this study,
the 40% decrease in mortality,
that was with a regular stone saw.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's why I got a regular sauna cause a doctor,
Rhonda Patrick told me that um,
the studies that have been done,
they've all been done with a regular sauna and she said there might be some
benefit for infrared sauna it,
but I don't know what's published.
What does it see if there's a benefit,
see if this,
they could say what's the benefit to infrared cooking my organs?
I don't even know it.
No,
I don't think so.
I think it's great for just feel amazing after that's supposedly what happens,
right.
It like gets deeper in your tissue or that it's supposed to go deeper inside.
I remember us texting back and forth,
I was like,
you gotta like if you do the infrared sauna for like a week,
it's a game changer.
It's just fun is too.
So I don't know.
I would like you to try regular sauna to,
how hot does the infrared yet a like 140 140 minutes in the air though too.
It's a difference.
It's not,
it doesn't heat the air.
Like you walk in and it feels,
it doesn't feel like it's that,
but that's just weird.
That's your microwave shit,
none of that,
man.
It's like hot pockets.
He ain't turn them into a hot pocket again.
That's what I'm saying.
I probably burning up all my organs right now,
but I don't know.
I love it.
I liked coming in and feeling that super heat or you go in there and you're
like,
oh,
it feels so good.
I love it.
Do you fuck with cold?
Do you ever do like cry or anything like that?
I tried that once and it was right after the infrared sauna there like try to
call.
It's just,
I don't know,
man.
It wasn't my thing.
What do you mean it wasn't my thing?
I didn't like how so?
Like it was fucking freezing.
No,
I wasn't not your thing.
It's just I don't want to,
I wouldn't do it.
I don't know.
No,
I love heat,
but the cold thing is like,
Nah,
I'm good.
I'm good on that.
Understand.
You know you love it.
I love it.
I do it too.
I love both of them.
Do you go back to back?
That's what they say you should do.
I have not gone back to back,
but I've gone and done both of them in a day.
I like,
I like hot yoga too.
I like hot yoga and then doing the Cryo,
which they say you shouldn't do because it'll give you a heart attack.
Oh,
doing it hot cold.
Who?
Pussy?
Yeah.
Who's doing being a man was getting a goddamn heart attack deaf up.
Who's getting a heart attack from?
Not Us,
not us.
He used to do hot yoga.
I need to get back into,
I just got to get flexible man.
It's just,
that's the tough thing about getting old and you know,
flexibility,
flexibility.
Because what they say most,
most older people die on the toilet because they can't get up.
You know,
they,
they have some problem
and they can't get up from wherever they are.
Is that real?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's a crazy way to go.
Just on the toilet.
You always imagine like Elvis,
like as you dined,
he'd be like,
Cam,
we know.
I just don't want to die.
Stupid.
Some stupid like you'll be reading,
uh,
in New York City.
Some guys just walking and something falls on him,
you know,
fraud.
Oh,
were a person.
How about that suicidal person lands on your fucking head?
I was at Adidas and uh,
the flagship in New York,
Adidas,
and like five minutes before I got there,
you know,
a person just jumped off and killed themselves right outside the store.
Like out of residents.
Chase.
Yeah.
It says that's one of the craziest ways to go.
Like the feeling of regret you must have when you feel the air under your feet
and you're falling.
You can't do nothing.
That's a wrap,
dude.
He made the decision.
You pulled the trigger.
Here comes the great beyond bang.
What goes through your mind when you're going down like that?
Like,
and it's your choice.
You know what I mean?
Probably filled with unbelievable terror.
Unbelievable tear.
Even though it's your choice.
There happened.
People that have survived jumps into the ocean,
they've jumped off the golden gate bridge all the time.
I mean,
it's like one of the number one suicide spots in the u s but some of them make
it,
they survive.
That would suck.
Yeah.
Or like,
if you really wanted to die and you didn't die,
maybe not.
Maybe you got a new lease on life,
he hit the water and you're like,
what am I alive?
Fuck.
I never could get myself to that place.
Like,
I,
I like my life too much right now.
Yeah.
Well,
you're happy and that's an awesome thing.
But you know,
when we're talking about spectrums,
there's clearly a spectrum of that.
You know,
and some people I think habit horrifically,
they just have what a forever,
whatever reason,
chemical inbounds,
life experiences that are awful,
PTSD,
whatever the formula is,
they have it to the point where it's almost unbearable.
Every day.
100%,
a hundred percent.
Like my dad,
you know,
he was,
he,
uh,
served our country in the army and it didn't seem to affect him at all.
But,
uh,
you know,
he has friends that it's affected.
I have friends that have served,
they're affected by it.
And what was that movie?
It was about being Ghazi.
Um,
I forgot John Krasinski did it,
but I had to interview the real guys that pulled off.
Got The people out of Benghazi in the normal world is so boring to them.
Like literally they got excited when they talked about,
you know how it feels that bullets whizzing by your head,
you knowing you shooting at people,
like literally the real world is so,
and that's why they keep going back because that's the only way they can get
that adrenaline rush,
which is,
you know,
to me I'm like,
that's crazy.
But to them,
that's where they get their high and that's,
that's a life to them.
That's how they're living.
And I interviewed the three or four soldiers that went out there and save these
people.
And
you saw that look in their eye,
you know what I mean?
It was like they would go back now if they could.
And they hated hearing how one of their own lost their lives up there.
You know,
where they were like,
I could've done something about that.
And that's what they talked about is like,
why we always want to go back is every time we hear one of our,
um,
one of our fallen soldiers,
they,
they fail.
We could have saved them.
And two of them were snipers and the other two were on the ground and they were
like,
man,
it's just,
it's just real life is,
is very tame for us.
You know,
it's almost a,
I'm putting what now I'm paraphrasing,
but I would say they think it's a bore just living our normal lives and unless
they're fighting for our country and saving people's lives,
like everything else is just boring.
Yeah.
I mean,
you're talking about literally life being turned up to 10.
There's nothing else that compares to it on the planet or other than being a
police officer.
Can you in a shoot out or,
or just just imagine like a police officer walking up to a car that's freaky
enough.
You don't know what's inside the box.
You're playing roulette.
You don't know what's inside that car.
You know?
Like,
look,
there are some bad police out there,
but as just put yourself in that spot where you're a cop getting out your car,
walking to a car with tinted windows,
knocking on the window,
you don't know what you're going to,
you don't know if it's a barrel of a shotgun.
You don't have no idea.
You have no idea.
People have to realize that that tension they carry with them all day.
They might have 20 of those interactions.
Absolutely all day and,
and,
and a couple of could've been really bad for you.
And if you have,
he gives him any bullshit or don't appreciate or respect that they're
immediately going to go,
oh,
okay.
Yeah,
he fucking asshole and you're the enemy now.
And it's horrible.
It's horrible that we give a person the kind of power that police officers have
when they abuse it,
but it's also horrible that we create this relationship between fellow citizens
of pro cop is just a citizen.
It's just one of us where we are the enemy.
If we're not following the book,
especially when the book is stupid,
like it's pot laws or something dumb like that.
Or you're catching guys getting jerked off like Jesus Christ.
You know,
I've been pulled over a couple of times and I got to say,
you know,
most of them,
like my dad,
you know,
they say a a black thing to do when you have a black father,
they tell you very early on when a cop pulls you over,
hands out,
let them see it.
You know,
it's taught to us when we're,
when we're born and raised and especially where I grew up.
So,
you know,
I even been profiled and you know,
like I'm half black,
you know,
you don't know what I really am.
A lot of people,
but I've been profiled so I know when I see,
when I hear the stories and I've been in cars with my friends that are dark
skinned black and they've been pulled over and it's a thing where you're upset
because you feel like you're being profiled.
But man,
once that cop walks over,
you need to show all due respect because they,
they control that game.
Now it's 100% their gang.
Once they pull up to your window,
you're in their cart.
We all should think that they are entirely necessary for a civilized aside,
100% and if you want to be able to call the police,
if some shit is going down,
you should appreciate them when they're there.
And you know this does not discount all the bad cops.
Yeah,
absolutely not discount all the things that we've all seen,
the shootings were unjustified punches or unjustified.
This is what we have to keep though perspective because there's so many
interactions.
There's so many cops out there that are dealing with PTSD all day long because
for a decade or two decades of their life,
they have been dealing with crime and violence all day long,
every day.
And they dress like the enemy.
They're not just a cop,
they're a cop west of where a cop outfit.
So everywhere you go,
like when you weren't playing quake and you playing team,
it goes quick.
Dude has a special flag over his head.
You know,
that's a target.
If you see,
if you see cops,
they're like bad guys.
See cops as the enemy.
You're being paid to be the enemy.
Even if you've never had an interaction of you're a bad guy and that's a cop.
That's the enemy.
And that is a crazy,
but it's interesting to ask people to be,
but even for people that don't have interactions with cops a lot,
they still considered the enemy.
Sure.
Cause if they pull you over for speeding,
like I,
it's gone through my mind.
It's like nobody's on the road right now.
Why are you pulling me over for speeding?
I'm not hurting anybody.
It's just a waste of time.
Well you're trying to write a ticket because they have to write a certain number
and that's,
and that's when I think it goes over the top where it's like come on now.
I was talking to a cop about that.
I said,
okay,
now let me ask you this.
What if everybody agreed to never speed?
Like we made up like a six month agreement in this country where we would never
speed and no one speed it and there was no more traffic violations in terms of
speeding tickets,
what the fuck would happen.
And he was like,
people would just get laid off left and right.
They would just quietly,
yeah,
he was just,
they were like,
I think they would just slash so the police department,
they put quotas on you cause you're a glorified revenue collector.
I mean that's what those guys,
you think that's a problem though.
Like when you're officially people over and I think that it all looks like
problems with the police and people start from the core.
And that's a major problem if you have to pull over people,
even if you're a cop and go,
eh,
they're not really doing anything bad.
But I have to meet my quota of tickets that starts from a very negative place.
Terrible,
terrible place to place.
Terrible place in,
terrible place for,
for both parties.
Terrible place for the cop to bury his head in the sand and realize he's writing
someone a ticket for no reason.
You know,
like you catch someone that speed limit 65 they're sick,
they're going 69 you pull them over like kit the fuck really,
how to,
you can't even pay attention.
Like there's no way,
unless I'm not looking at the road like it,
unless I have cruise control or I'm not looking at the road all,
I might get to 60 9:00 AM I back up to 65 again,
even if I'm trying to go the speed limit,
but I know people that have been pulled over four miles over 100% yet,
but as a driver of that car going four miles over,
you're pissed.
Yeah.
Like automatically.
You just got jacked in your mind.
You're protecting and we all know he's writing a ticket just to write a ticket.
It's probably the 27th or 28th of the month.
Yep.
And they got to meet their quota and he just put like,
that's where they are driving to Vegas is the worst.
They set up traps and especially close to the end of the month.
You know,
if you're driving to Vegas,
go to speed limit because we're waiting for you.
I got pulled over by plane.
Oh,
have you seen this?
Go into Vegas.
They have planes that now radar you.
They don't even,
and then they send out cop cars.
So to put you on the radar as you and then a cop car pulls you over lay.
Yes.
Yeah.
And that was the last time we went to Vegas.
I went with my wife and son and we got pulled like a cop car came out of
nowhere.
And my wife,
here's the difference.
You know the,
this shows the,
my wife is white from Wyoming.
Right.
And this is the big difference.
That's real white.
That that's what it's like pilgrim.
That's like Casper the friendly ghost white.
That's like cowboy white.
Right.
My own hands loosen literally.
Cowboys up there.
Wyoming cowboys.
Yeah.
Did you,
your wife grew up on a ranch?
No.
Shit.
No,
no,
no.
I think they've cities.
Yeah,
they,
she's grew up in Gillette,
Gillette,
Wyoming.
The fuck is that Gillette Wyoming people.
They're 80 I think 3000 no,
seriously.
They're like the Brady bunch.
I'm married into the Brady plan.
Like,
seriously,
they're real life,
right?
It's like,
good morning,
Michael.
How are you?
Like they are those peats kind of cool.
No,
it's great.
So a cop pulls us over for this Vegas Strip,
and this is the difference in cultures we have.
And this is why I tried to tell my wife when the cop came over his name,
let's say officer Andrew,
he comes over,
I'm very polite.
I said,
yes sir,
you got it.
No problem.
I was speeding.
My wife and the cop goes,
we pulled you over by a plane.
So it gives me a ticket.
I'm like,
hey officer,
I have a great day.
It's like,
you too,
sir.
My wife is in the backseat when my son rolls down the window,
when he's walking away and goes,
excuse me,
uh,
how do you know it was this black SUV?
I see lots of black SUV.
It's passing us and it's from a plane.
Are you serious?
And I'm like,
I'm about to die.
The cop turns back around like comes to my side of the window and says,
excuse me Ma'am and eh,
but just a privilege to be able to talk to a cop like that cause she has no
idea.
She has no idea.
That's the real white privilege.
That's the real one.
And I'm like,
and I'm like telling him to tell me about,
I'm telling the cop,
I'm saying,
hey baby,
it's okay.
I was speeding.
Do you can have this onstage?
No,
you fucking shit dude.
That's hilarious.
And I'm like,
you should for sure talk about the of stage.
It's,
it's just,
it scared me because I was scared because she's the cop comes back around.
Write that down right now.
Okay.
Keep that pad.
Write it down.
You must talk about this on stage.
Wife,
top wall.
That shit life.
Kathleen privilege.
Plain
radar black.
Yes.
A Wyoming cowboy.
White people.
Okay.
We've got a whole suite.
We've got stang too.
So shoehorns horseshoe.
He comes back over and he's trying to explain to my wife about a plane and she's
given this cop attitude.
Oh No.
Well,
we drive off,
I go,
baby,
you cannot do that.
Like you almost killed me.
She was like,
stop being ridiculous.
I'm like,
no,
you really know.
You really could have got me killed.
You'd never,
never,
no wrong guy.
Wrong place,
wrong time,
wrong history,
wrong background,
wrong state of mind that he's in.
What if he didn't like a black dude married to a white woman?
For sure.
Yeah.
Like,
and she didn't get that.
But now she gets that because we have a son.
You know what I mean?
So I think once you have a multi ethnic son now she's like,
oh,
I'm all about marijuana.
I'm all about,
she doesn't like,
she's all about the ethnic cartoons and not the white.
She's trying,
she's trying,
she's got a good mindset.
She's trying to,
in a family's trying,
you know sucks that anybody has to ever worry about getting accidentally shot by
a cop.
And the problem I think is not going to go away until the problem of crime goes
away.
And that's not going to happen either.
So like what do we do to make life safer for everybody?
That's a real good fucking question.
Well,
I think awareness for sure.
Like people being aware of all these videos.
That's one thing that I think that black black lives matter did that people
don't want to accept,
but it's really important as it became a national thought.
Yes.
It's not just another story in the news.
It's a national thought like this is a movement to try to eradicate this and all
the times where you've seen guys plant guns on people after they've shot.
I'm like the OCC videos.
Yeah.
You see videos of black people with no guns getting shot and then here's the
problem.
They go to court and then the cops are innocent.
You see the one where the guy throws the gun down on the ground or was it,
was it a taser?
What did he throw down on the ground?
There was like he shot him and then as he's coming down to the body,
he dropped something on the ground when I was growing up,
at least,
I don't know when it changed,
but cops were supposed to shoot and not to kill you,
but to handicap you like shoot you in the leg,
shoot you in the arm.
She tests are not that good a shot.
There's a lot of cops that are just not good at shooting guns.
I mean there's a lot of that are military trains that are very professional and
very serious who are,
but it's like,
look,
I watched a video the other day of a guy getting in an altercation as off duty
cop got into an altercation with this guy and he tried to pull his gun out.
The guy grabbed him,
grabbed his risk.
I did not know how to fight at all and probably only knew how to like shoot
people.
He gets taken down.
The Guy,
obviously new Jujitsu took,
took them down,
mounted him,
took the gun from him,
threw the gun away and beat the fuck out of him from the Mount Pounding Hawk eye
turns his back,
he gets his back,
he's beating the shit out of them.
It's horrific because
this cop thought he was safe and pulled his gun.
But this isn't like one example of was just because someone's a cop doesn't mean
they're a well trained,
prepared because there are those out there for sure.
But there were also some slops like I've seen some guys that are there a cop.
I'm like,
Bro,
you can't run a block.
Fuck are you a cop?
Yeah.
You know,
like this is a ridiculous position for you to put yourself in and anybody else.
You're trying to protect your handicapped by Gluttony,
you know?
But,
but at the same time,
we do need them.
We need need,
need the cops.
We need them to be more respected and appreciated.
They're not very respected and appreciated by a lot of people.
I think that's a huge miss service.
What I hate about this conversation,
whatever side they're on,
what the cops are going to pull,
whatever they want because we've talked negative or not negative.
We said some things about,
and I hate how we're in such a polar place where,
Oh,
you're either for him or against it and that's like with everything and that's
what I hate.
You can't have a conversation anymore and that's where we're at right now.
It's like you can't say anything wrong with cops because then you don't support
the cops.
If you support the cops,
then you'll get attacked by the other side going,
oh well they kill innocent people.
I know.
And someone can take your clip of anything that you've said today without
further elaboration,
because most of what you said,
you further elaborate.
Absolutely.
They could take that one snippet and just put a little clip up somewhere.
Michael Yo said this,
or worse yet quoted.
This is what he said about cops.
People look,
fuck him.
I thought he was pro cop like this.
Well that's the world we live in today.
Yeah,
this is the world we live in and that's why it's so horrible,
man.
Well,
it isn't.
It's not.
It is like that.
That part is horrible,
but it's the best time to be alive ever.
The best time to be alive in terms of our ability to understand our effect on
each other,
the best time to be alive in terms of our ability to access information,
the best time for for if something is going on,
you will alert people that this thing like a crime is taking 100% we could
spread the news of it so quick.
We just have to,
we were just not used to so much.
We're not used to so much that we have to deal with all day and we're not
designed for so much and it happened in 35 years.
You know,
like,
like just think about like our parents,
right.
When we were growing up,
the TV was black and white and then it went color and that was the big thing for
them.
For us there were no cell phones or Internet.
Yeah.
And then in our,
in like the last 35 years I'll,
I don't think you'll ever see a technology boom like in this last 35 years.
So many advancements happen so quick and that's why we today can't react to him
fast enough.
We don't know like,
like now parents are doing like parents that are our age are doing the same
things the kids are doing.
Where my dad never cared about playing a tare or doing anything.
He had totally different interests where now the kids that are coming up since
this boom is so fast,
we're still learning new technology and now our kids are learning it with us and
there's no separation.
I I agree and I think it's definitely like untreaded territory,
but I disagree
that that will never see a boom in technology like we've already seen.
I think we're,
we haven't even scratched the surface really.
Yeah.
We haven't even scratched when you have,
but I guess I'm saying things that change the world like there was no internet
Joe do now.
There isn't that Elon Musk is working on called neuro link and I don't know
exactly how this works because he wouldn't exactly explain it,
but the concept is about increasing the bandwidth between human brain activity
and information somehow or another to get information quicker to you and have
you access it in a quicker manner.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
It's something you wear on your head.
Some dude just tried it.
Jamie.
There's an article that just,
I just found it.
I'm looking at her.
Yeah.
Some dude just said I might or might not have tried Elon Musk's neuro link,
like he's kind of like bound by silence,
but there is a real possibility that think about what,
here's,
here's how to look at it.
Think about why fi right Wifi is in this room.
We use it.
You can access,
you could shut your phone off and turn your Wifi on and you'd be able to access
all the information on the Internet,
but where's that coming from?
Where is that?
It's in the air in the sky.
It's all around us.
If you can wear something that picks up on that in the same,
what picks up on Wifi in the same way it picks up on cellular signals,
whether it's four g or five G,
which is coming out soon,
which is supposed to be an unstoppable and changeable.
If that can feed information directly to your brain through something that you
were just,
the way they do these,
you know they have these electrodes they put on your head and they send magnetic
pulses.
Different parts of the brain helps people with traumatic brain injuries,
helps people with depression.
They've been able to do this by taking these little things and they stick them
to your head and they,
they'd send this pulsating magnet in there.
They can already affect the brain with external stimulation.
They already know how to do that.
If they can figure out how to do that in a much more sophisticated way.
We are on the edge of becoming cyborgs and it's not far away.
We're talking about within the next decade,
maybe two decades.
There's Gunna be something that changes a person and makes you like if you are a
person with a limited education and no phone,
think about how,
but then think about how little access to the knowledge base you had.
Now,
if you're a person with the limited access to information and education,
but you have a phone and that phone is online,
you have everything,
so that changes everything.
This person now can access all the knowledge.
I mean,
it's not perfect if you Google things.
Some of the things are bullshit.
Yeah,
some articles are dumb.
They don't make sense,
but you have the possibility of finding all the information is now in the
future.
I think that as going,
that's going to be escalated and it's going to be escalated exponentially.
There's going to be some new leaps in technology that happen that guys like you
and I that don't work in the field.
We're not.
We're going to go see it.
Common is people who are working on these things right now and they're competing
with people in China and Russia and all over the world that are also working on
these technologies and they're going to get through and they're going to make
something and that's something he's going to change reality as we know it,
and it's probably right around the corner the same way cell phones and the
Internet changed our reality as compared to our parents.
This is going to change it,
but the neuro thing is it I,
I get that your brain gets it right away,
but I don't know how it works,
but,
but let's say your brain gets it.
You put this machine on like this and then it sends it straight to your brain.
What's the difference of that?
Besides quicker than you being on the computer and looking up,
you're still getting the same,
so I don't think that's the case,
but you're getting the same information.
I think that's how it works.
What does this guy say?
This is a April fools joke.
It's an April fool's joke.
Yeah.
Oh,
what is the title of the Article?
Let me try a neuro link of the time,
but oh,
really funny.
But let's say,
and I know you don't know about,
but let's say you put it on a device in all the information goes through your
brain,
you're still getting the same information.
Maybe not.
What have you ever seen someone use an Exoskeleton,
you know,
next to nothing.
And what does that exoskeleton is like suit that you put on that's like,
say if you work in a factory,
it allow you to pick up much heavier things.
Like remember the movie aliens,
Sigourney Weaver,
she's fucking up that thing.
She's inside that robot.
That's like a giant robotic exoskeleton.
This is an exoskeleton that they use for people that are paralyzed.
It helps them walk.
Okay.
Um,
they also are developing exoskeletons.
Oh,
that's a chair,
Huh?
That's pretty dope.
Was extra legs.
Oh,
that's pretty dope.
Um,
there's things that help people like that Gout,
right there is not a big person,
but she can work in a factory and you can carry things that are much heavier
than what you would ordinarily be able to carry it.
Okay.
Now they think that as technology moves and improves,
they're going to get to the point where they develop,
which essentially like an iron man suit.
That's like an exoskeleton.
You know the iron man suit,
like when he wears that,
he's invisible.
He can fly,
he can smash things and pick things up and throw things that's going that that
is entirely possible,
that this is going to be our future,
that there's going to be suits that we wear that make us impervious.
Look at,
this guy's got one,
lets them fly around and he's got rockets that come out of his,
he thinks the government,
whatever approved that for us to get and have a chance.
It's not whether or not they improve,
approve it.
It doesn't have anything to do with them.
It has to do with the technologist.
It has to do with the scientists.
That has to do with the geniuses that are creating these tow these things
because they're going to come in waves and these fucking dummies that don't even
understand what Facebook is.
Yeah.
These are the same guys are going to stop these people from putting out ironman
suits.
They're not going to tell them until it's way too late,
too late.
There were,
they're already the one,
they tell them they're going to make them for sale and they're not going to give
them the option as to whether or not they're regulate them.
They're just going to get,
they're going to make them for people and then you're gonna have to figure out
the laws once people have them.
And then once grandma has one and all of a sudden grandma's playing tennis again
and you tell me grandma can't play tennis because some bad guys want to use an
Exoskeleton to rob a bank because that shit's gone.
All of it's coming.
Bulletproof exoskeleton.
I still,
everything that you've said so far still to me is not bigger than not have an
internet well being or the attended door,
but we don't know if that tech not like the thing that you can like talk into
your phone and you could say,
Hey Siri,
when was the constitution formulated?
You know,
Hey Siri,
what was the first draft of the Declaration of independence written on?
You can do,
you can ask those questions.
Is Serial Angeles questions.
Google search will answer those questions for you.
But what if you just know it?
What if that thought interfaces with your brain in a way where it describes
things maybe in symbols or direct feed of information through some unfathomable
technology that literally just permeates language.
It's just gets through all that.
If I speak to Jews,
you information,
should I speak to you in a different language,
it would automatically translated things like that.
That's,
well they already could do that.
You know they have these Google earbuds.
Yeah.
This pixel buds.
I think they're called real.
If that worked,
would they just get rid of school or at school and be to tell you how to work it
needs scholars because you would need to know whether or not this,
this stuff is accurate.
You would need women and men who are educated in this and that's,
this is one of the reasons why the scientific method so important.
One of the reasons why when people shit on like ridiculous things like um,
like grievance studies and a lot of the things that are overcoming universities
these days,
what you're,
you're,
you're taking away with your preposterous social justice ideology.
You're taking away from the real pursuit of knowledge and information because
you want it to match up with your ideology.
This is a dangerous time to fuck with information because people already pooling
up in these little echo chambers where they,
you know,
whether it's a message boards or Twitter groups that you're in and,
and they,
they feed off of each other and agree on each other with each other all the
time.
Yeah,
that'd be really careful with information these days.
And also,
you know what,
they have to keep scholars to keep the real information because it's just like
that a one show,
I forgot what it's called,
black something black box,
black,
black mirror.
Like they can change reality.
Like literally like if you don't have scholars to oversee this stuff,
that can be like,
oh,
you know what?
Slavery never happened or this never happened.
And it would go away because the people born today will never know.
There's people that to this day will deny the Armenian genocide.
There's people to this day that denied that or this is a real thing.
Yeah.
There are certain human beings it denied that the w w what's it going to be like
a hundred years from now?
I mean,
how many of those people will exist then?
There's a lot of those circumstances in life where you have to be really careful
about what information is,
what's process like we had.
We have to,
you have to be 100% if you're saying
something that is a historical record and you can't fuck with it at all,
but they are now,
but the,
everybody has a history.
That's the reasons why all religions are different.
Right?
Because everybody has their own little version of history.
I mean,
this is one of the reasons why many different religions have stories of Jesus,
but they very,
they're very,
yeah.
Yeah.
He's telling the truth.
Well,
I,
I mean it's,
it's thing where,
where,
what's scary to me about this world today is that misinformation is out there
all the time and people believe it and people just,
people don't read anymore.
They just listened to the bullet point and screamed that out.
Like literally,
and I don't want to get political or anything,
but,
but I remember when everybody was saying Obama is going to raise taxes and they
were interviewing people that didn't even make $30,000 say,
oh,
he's going to raise my taxes.
It's like,
Nah,
he's not even talking about you,
but you're yelling at a bullet point.
If you would have read the article,
you would have read,
you are fine.
That's the thing people are in today.
We want to yell out bullet points.
If Fox News,
if you watch that and they say this,
you're just yelling at that,
but you never read.
Like if CNN is your thing,
you're just yelling what they're saying but you don't read like me,
I watch both.
I actually read both articles.
I could talk politics all day.
Like,
I think,
I think there are good things that Republicans do.
I think there's good things that,
uh,
Democrats,
I think Democrats right now are in a state where there they fight amongst each
other.
They're going to crush each other before the election even comes.
It's like Obama set.
It's a circle and fire squad.
They're shooting at each other and,
and here's the thing,
the good thing about the republican's bad or good,
however you take it,
if one of them says,
let's go.
They go with Democrats.
It's Ah,
let's talk about it.
I mean,
it's more intelligent way to do it,
but they don't have each other's back,
I feel as much.
And that's why their messaging is always off.
That's why Donald Trump,
Donald Trump could have never been a democrat.
Like if Donald Trump said,
I want to run for president and been a Democrat,
they theirs,
theirs,
they would mesh well the Republican's,
it works because,
oh,
we just want to stay in charge and whatever he says we're going to roll with,
you know,
George Bush a weapons about let's go,
it's just a hundred percent behind it.
Where I think they think that is,
I want us,
you know,
when I grew up,
I,
I voted for Bush after nine 11.
Right.
Cause I'm from Texas,
you know,
and I think it's the odd a lot.
Uh,
I had a lot of shit
that,
oh,
we want to pay back in.
It's,
I don't want to say good old boys,
but it's like,
Hey Rah,
Rah,
let's go.
Yeah.
That's the whole thing.
It's,
it's more than you remember when the flags are on everybody's car.
Oh yeah.
And it was like we were all behind it too.
That was the weirdest.
I remember I was driving somewhere and uh,
I made a turn on the street near my house and it was a one or two days after
nine 11 and I never saw more flags on cars in my life.
It was like the world changed.
Oh.
Like everybody had a flag on their car and everybody cared about each other and
they send that in.
That's the thing that's sad about the world today is I tell,
I tell everybody,
and I'm not a politician,
but I will say this,
when you have two different teams that are rivals,
build,
never come to the same conclusion unless there's tragedy [inaudible] right?
When that was one of the things that Reagan said once when we was talking about,
they were meeting with Gorbachev and he said,
I often wonder how we would put our differences aside if we were faced with an
alien threat from another world.
Oh,
we totally would like the idea that this global conflict that we think about in
terms of Russia versus United States.
But if there was some fucking aliens coming down here,
war,
a world style,
it would be independence day.
Everybody would join forces everybody.
Cause now you have a common enemy.
And I also believe the way that our country's being run right now,
you know,
Trump is good at making an enemy that he survives off an enemy.
This person's a enemy right now.
Everybody attack.
Now this person's an enemy.
Everybody attack them.
I'm not saying it's right or wrong,
I'm just saying that's the way it is.
Yeah.
He just fucks with people.
Apparently there's some dude that's his head of secret security or secret
service that he calls dumbo cause dude has big ears.
He replaced him.
How he fired him.
Dude.
He is.
He's a fucking wild man and he's probably on speed.
That's what I think.
But it's crazy man.
Like I'm just watching this and he's hilarious.
If it wasn't the fact that you think that like the moral fiber of our country's
deteriorating.
Is this the guy who does have big ears big and as massive beers?
Wow.
Well,
well but,
but I know a lot of people have big ears that I like dearly,
but don't you?
But don't you believe this show,
let's be honest,
if America,
like the whole country could look in the mirror when Donald Trump was elected,
it's a reflection of America.
When he got,
when he got voted,
it's a reflection of a percentage of us.
No,
no,
no.
But egotistical,
it's a can of some upside.
I don't want to generalize like in terms of like say that's America.
I'm would,
I would for a joke.
Yeah,
but I mean if you were being serious,
but I am being serious.
Mobile Den,
why we're there is why was there the women's march where millions of women,
let me tell you,
let me tell you why.
Because I think Donald Trump,
here's a,
here's what,
when everybody was depressed down,
Trump was president.
I go,
you got to look at the positives.
If Hillary was elected,
those women would have never got together to march.
Donald Trump has brought more people together against him.
More group.
We were marching.
Americans were marching for Muslims after Donald Trump became president.
The positivity that Donald Trump has created with the opposition and the
togetherness.
You had a million women march because Donald Trump was president.
You have people marching for the Muslims.
But because Donald Trump was president,
he's brought for the first time.
I feel like they,
the side that opposes Donald Trump,
they're more
together than ever.
And even though we say it's ripped the country apart,
you know,
because you know there's some problems in this country,
but it has brought a bunch of people together and I don't think if Hillary was
president,
you wouldn't have had the women march.
You wouldn't have had the Marshfield Muslims.
You wouldn't have people back in immigrants.
She's just start executing men's.
She would do,
she'd take them out in the middle of town squares or shooting them first with
bill.
Bill would be the first one had him on television.
Well that was the whole thing.
Like
public execution.
Yeah.
Just like I ran are just like our allies in Iran.
But yeah,
but don't,
but don't you think as I ran,
do public executions?
Is it Syria?
Syria does.
Right,
but don't you think like when Hillary didn't stand up to build,
that's where she lost everybody.
It started way before the election because women wanted her to stand up to him
back then.
He don't know what she did or didn't write it.
We'll just go what she did publicly and publicly.
Why would she do that?
It seems like it's crazy to do.
Like why?
Why are you,
you're,
you're a dignified person.
You're going to publicly,
well not trash and,
but you don't have to stand next to him.
Even Melania Trump bounces on Trump in a,
she's
like,
she's like,
no,
Killary without bill didn't exist.
I think that guy was a Dick Slang in bucking ear and he made his way into the
motherfucking White House and she rode that wave.
There was a Giant v 12 sucking gasoline,
like it was going on style blowing,
a big wake behind it.
And she was hanging on to that fucking wakeboard line.
Jesus,
she wasn't Gut Natta Arkansas,
she wasn't getting in the White House.
She wasn't a secretary of state settled down with that nonsense.
So it's kind of like,
hey,
you know what you got yourself into,
is that what you're saying?
Well,
there's that and there's also,
she's always liar.
Yeah.
Like,
and maybe it's she's a liar because she's a politician,
but when just you compare what was public like her knowledge of what went wrong
with the email servers and all that jazz and many other instances too that just
one we'll talk about and what Komi said when call me was examining the evidence
and what what they did wrong and what she said they did wrong.
They're very different.
They're very different things,
very different things.
And this is politics,
right?
If your base hears you say something that isn't true but you say it with
confidence,
even though the evidence doesn't support it,
that argument takes place and it blurs the gray area in the middle between guilt
and innocence.
Do you,
do you think when,
when uh,
somebody gets elected president,
they have a meeting with Elac and then they say these are the things you can go
after and these are the things you can't because if you go after this we can't
protect you from it.
I really believe those conversations happen in the White House.
Like do you think they,
they say they can't protect yourself?
I think like I mean after the Jews.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying like there's certain organizations like the Rockefellers,
there's certainly from the Roth child there,
certain organizations you talk about the CFR,
no,
I'm going to say it doesn't let a Bohemian Grove,
I just think there's a list of corporations,
big corporations that run America that they say you can't go after.
Because a lot of presidents go in there and saying,
I'm going to do this against this car.
I'm not going to even say the corporation cause I want to live in.
I feel that secret service really caused these people in the presidents and go,
Hey,
this is who you can't go after.
Here's who you can't.
And if you do go after those,
you kind of on your own.
Cause we won't be able to save because they're too powerful.
Well,
I believe in that giant corporations that have incredible influence on
politicians because they still reach and spend so much money to keep them in
power and get them into power and help contribute to the campaigns and then they
scratch each other's backs.
If the president were to go in and say,
I'm going to get rid of all lobbyists,
that president would not make it through his term.
Um,
well it's hard to say that.
No,
it's not.
there's too much money,
Joe.
I mean,
I don't want too much money.
It's too much money.
If I'm gonna agree with you in this day and age,
it's hard to say that because you'd have to get everybody on board with killing
a president.
I think they definitely did it with Kennedy.
Oh,
you mean,
I think if 100% you know,
I was talking to,
uh,
you know,
do you have to get everybody to Bowers?
No,
but do you have to get everybody on board?
Yeah.
I mean it just takes,
get everybody on board or knows about it because otherwise people are going to
tell if you,
if you go and kill the fucking president,
you have to get a lot of people on board as what we're,
we're probably going to get raided by the secret service right now.
But I'm saying if you want to kill president,
it's not like it used to be.
I think it used to be less consequential.
Not that it was always,
I mean like John Wilkes booth days,
right?
Yeah.
Easier to kill the president and
then Kennedy ways year to kill a president in 1963 then it has killed president
2019 could you still do it?
Yeah,
but you're probably going to get caught.
Like you would probably get caught.
It let you would have to have,
I mean it would have to be all,
you'd have to have a tiny small circle of fucking sociopaths and psychopaths and
they all agree to keep it hush.
To me it's just one person calling another person saying do this,
pay him off and then you can get caught.
But one look.
But you have secret service.
You have a military protecting them.
It's different because you'd have to,
it's a lot of layers to get past all that you know and someone won't have to
make a mistake and mapping like that was one of the things I said about Dealey
Plaza and they rolled Kennedy through there.
Like what fucking security person would ever agree to let someone roll through
with the convertible with bill the bill down.
Yeah,
and then also you have to take that long,
slow turn where you know it's not you just drive by going 50 miles an hour.
You've got to get your gun out and shoot them quick.
No,
the guy was driving slow.
It's ridiculous.
It's like you're asking for someone to get assassinated,
but I just,
I just really like,
there are rules like that will never ever know about,
but once you get in there they're like,
hey,
here's what you need to know.
Here's what you need to know not to go against.
I would think that if anybody's going to tell us that it's Trump,
I think the best thing that could ever happen is that Trump gets out of his
terms in the White House and just starts talking.
It's start,
it starts writing books.
Tell us everything.
Yeah.
You want to be the king of the world,
right.
A fucking a huge book on exactly what it's like the day you become the
president.
That would be insane.
How,
how do you think he's going to be treated once it gets out though?
They'll love him.
You think so?
They love Bush.
People hated Bush.
They called Bush a war criminal.
Now he's an adorable grandpa.
Paints.
No,
it's true.
It's true.
Look,
man,
what a whatever people be hating Obama when he was in office,
they're going to love him within a few years.
I mean,
most people that were supporters of Obama,
they love him now.
I mean,
he's like,
uh,
yeah,
I,
I mean,
I don't know.
I think they're going to,
I think a certain percentage of the population loves Trump right now,
period.
And you know,
they have reasons to back it up in terms of like the economy,
what they think is happening with job creation,
all these different things that he's doing that may or may not have devastating
implications depending on who you talk to.
That's an expert.
And I'm not one.
Yeah,
me neither.
But there's obviously,
and then also people say,
wow,
this was a trend that was actually going on during the Obama administration.
He's just riding the wave.
Maybe I'm too stupid.
I don't understand that stuff,
but I'm saying in terms of numbers,
it's not like the country is completely imploding right now.
I mean,
maybe some people buy some people's metric.
It's not doing as well as he would like to pretend it is probably.
But my thing,
it doesn't even matter.
Like when they say the stocks are up and all that,
it's,
it's what matters is your personal life.
Are you in a better place because he's president.
But for some people that are not right.
Some people like if you get rounded up by ice,
no you're not.
Yeah,
you're not,
you know,
I mean,
that's horrible.
This is the worst time ever for perception of us in terms of like the way we
handle immigrants.
Well,
you know,
you know the bad part about immigrants,
it's all bad.
But you know,
the problem is they've,
they've dealt with this problem.
Why for the last 30,
40 years.
I mean,
and if they make nicer facilities,
let's say they know they're coming so they don't have enough judges.
The,
the facilities were horrible.
So let's say they make nicer facilities.
Then the government thinks the whole thinking of the government is,
if we do that,
then that's going to encourage more to come because now it's nice.
Yeah.
They're like,
Bro,
you get over there.
I see a shower.
They have delicious food.
They have a taco stand.
It was fucking party over that Brown Margarita is he partied with the guards.
Once you get to know them,
they're good guys and that's the thing.
It's like what do you do?
What do you do?
Like I think,
I think this is a problem that will take generations to fix and really there is
a problem.
The only way it's really going to get fixed really is two ways.
One,
you got to make drugs legal and two,
you got to prop up all these countries,
all these countries that are third world countries where these people are
fleeing because they don't have any possibility.
There's no hope for them wherever they are.
If they're an incredibly poor countries,
there's no future there.
They don't,
they don't have the resources.
They don't have anything to do.
So the only way you can keep people happy on a global scale as you've got to
figure out like we have the highest of the highest,
right?
Yeah.
Like wealthy people in the industrialized Western world,
right.
And the lows,
the lows are people that lived in there that are living in these places that are
disease ridden,
poverty stricken,
horrible.
With no future you got,
we've got to figure out a way to bring everybody to a comfortable middle all
over the world so that there's no extreme poverty in any location anywhere.
We want to eradicate diseases.
Okay.
For sure we do.
Right?
We all do.
Don't we want to eradicate the problem?
The Dis ease of poverty is a dis ease.
It's a terrible feeling to be poor and scrounging for food in a crime ridden
environment.
And the only way to fix that is put attention on those areas and use money to
try to raise it up.
They're not going to raise up on their own.
They never have.
They never and never will.
Yeah.
I just think globally if,
if,
if people ever could get their shit together and this is what I hope this is my,
if I had like a pipe dream of technology,
that technology gets us to a place where we can read each other's minds.
And I think this is a possible,
and I think once we can read each other's minds,
we can understand that we're not that dissimilar.
There were,
were not nearly as far apart as we think we are and that most of our problems
that we have,
our problems of ego and problems of ideology and problems of ethics and morals
and,
and truth and lies and that reading each other's minds will sort a lot of that
out.
And then we're going to figure out a way to,
I don't want to say like for redistribution of wealth,
I don't think you should just give people things.
Where I think you should do is try to figure out a way to rebuild communities
and give people opportunities to live better lives.
And we have to do that global I think.
But I think the problem with today is presented to cause I listened to both
sides.
When you travel as a comic,
you'll people just come up to you and tell you their views on just random
things.
So you're from both sides.
One side is like,
I don't want to just give out stuff for free.
You know,
I,
why should I give them stuff?
I worked hard for mine and the other,
you got other people that go,
well,
we need to help everyone out because we are the world type of situation.
You know both,
right?
It's confusing.
There are 100% both right,
but you don't want to give people stuff,
but you don't want to just,
you got lucky.
You got lucky as fuck.
You're born in America.
I mean,
you're from Texas.
I'm from Boston,
dude.
We're,
we're from like the industrialized Western World in the,
the pinnacle of civilization in terms of like opportunity.
There's never been a place like we're the luckiest
fucking people that are a for the planet.
Anybody who doesn't acknowledge that you gotta be crazy,
man.
I was.
I became friends with this lady at a restaurant and me and my wife and son would
always go in there and we got really close and she was just talking about like,
you know,
our family's from Ecuador and her kids,
she can't afford her kids to be over here.
So she's sitting in a school over there and she keeps sending money over there.
But like it's riddled with gangs,
nothing but gangs out there.
And if they find out you're an America sending money back,
the hold your family hostage,
you know what I mean?
And it's,
and that's real.
People don't believe that.
They think they owe.
That's not,
it's real.
Like this lady we've known for over like eight years and she tells these stories
about like her sending her money and she has a person out there that,
that basically,
you know,
lives in a little house and keeps everything secret because if it comes out that
she sending money to him,
Bill,
they'll hold that family hostage and I'll have to keep yours off and shit.
Yeah.
Like it's bad,
it's bad.
And we're living here,
you know,
we're lucky we're doing this podcast,
but there are people struggling.
And when I hear people go,
ah,
you know,
that's their problem.
Nah,
that's,
that's terrible.
The worlds,
you're a,
you're an awful human being.
Perspective sucks for sure.
It's terrible and it's going on all over the world and it's creating this and I
feel that,
you know,
we're creating this me,
me,
me situation.
But I also think we need to also have conversations about it.
I did a,
I did a show in Kansas City and I always talk about when I do stand up,
I don't talk politics.
So you know,
you do the local press and things and there were people that come out to my
shows and Trump hats,
like literally wearing Trump hats,
sat front row and did that to fuck with you?
I don't know.
But I thought we did also,
I don't care what they probably did,
they probably did cause cause after the show literally and when I say Trump
supporters,
like they look,
I mean like the big Husky Guy,
hey,
how are you doing it?
Like that type of thing.
And they go,
we hurt.
Our wife said you weren't going to talk politics so we won't see.
You know,
and,
and then she goes,
he's right.
You didn't,
you know,
and Oh,
when they wanted to see we we're going to sit up front where I Trump,
pat support our leader case you crack any funnies about his aren't scanners
fucked up.
Hey.
And I didn't,
I did it because that's not my comedy.
But they bought all,
basically they bought tons of merch because I didn't do it and they all said
said something that was important.
And I think this is important to know when you try to make a point to somebody,
when you start off yelling at them,
it's never going to go well.
If you can explain it to him through your eyes and not yell,
have a conversation.
Because I talk a lot about like,
you know,
I talk a lot about growing up in an all white neighborhood in the racist things
that I encountered and I didn't yell at them and I didn't say I hate white
people.
I just told my point of view.
And they actually were open in,
they actually respond.
I understand now.
You know,
nobody's ever explained it to us like that and I think it's conversation
not because we watch TV.
It's all about you suck.
You suck.
Well,
let me tell you why.
You got to start from a place,
put it like this.
I don't know if you've heard of this green deal where they want to take 70% of
anyone that makes over $10 million,
70% of their income.
That's hilarious.
It's the dumbest thing ever.
AOC,
right?
Yeah.
It's the dumbest thing ever.
I mean,
I wasn't calling her.
No,
no,
no.
I like her,
but hey,
good luck.
Pitch as expression.
Yes.
I like her too.
I like it.
But I will agree with her that,
but I like her.
But what I'm saying is my friend was like,
oh,
you know,
if the Democrats win,
that's going to get passed because we hate rich people.
And I go,
that's the problem.
We're starting at hate.
The reason why you think it's going to pass because you think people hate rich
people see it and that's,
you got to have a conversation.
First of all,
you've got incompetent use of funds.
Like where does the money go?
Oh our tax that if you tax the rich that all of a sudden all the problems will
stop existing is so silly.
You still have been competent people that are distributing the money,
they're just create more jobs.
There'll be more red tape and more in debt.
Yeah.
Well we got to do is figure out a real plan for engineering our civilization
better.
That's what people have to do and they should be like real discussion from like
real experts,
biologists,
historians,
people who really understand he was a psychologist.
People really understand human beings really understand what's wrong with our
society today and we have an open discussion,
but you know that never got that.
But that can never happen.
Of course it can,
but no,
no,
no.
Right now because of the government.
Because here's the thing,
what do you mean?
And that can happen.
It's just we have to look at it in terms of a real priority.
But no,
it goes by,
it goes by the whoever party's in charge of their priorities.
It's not like my problem is to make it a priority for the nation.
That's what I'm saying.
But impossible.
But until you have a person,
I believe everything can be fixed.
This is a simple fix.
If you just elect a person that takes some republican values and some democratic
values,
the thing is right now in politics,
you have to be one or the other.
Like if I,
if a person came in and go,
you know what?
I like these Republican ideas.
I liked these democratic ideas,
less role.
I'm a be down the middle and less role with Polk called being a centrist.
Yeah,
that exists.
But in these to win it.
But that can happen.
It can happen.
All of it.
But until that happens,
but until that happens,
what does that mean though?
Does it every four years we figured out what happens.
Right?
And before Trump won,
we never thought a reality show fucking guy could win.
But that guy won.
Yeah.
And you go,
okay,
well now we know that happens.
All of this stuff can happen.
This is not like,
we're not asking for alchemy.
We're not trying to turn lead into gold.
We're trying to figure out a way,
but you're going against the system that then is is there's a new system.
The new system is the system of public opinion,
which is readily accessible.
Absolutely.
And that's never happened before.
There's never been a time where everyone had a say in one way,
shape or form.
Whether it's through commenting through Instagram or Twitter or social media.
That's one of the reasons why upholding the freedom of speech and these things
is so important.
Even if people were saying things you don't agree with,
the only way this all gets sorted out as we get to figure out a way to express
ourselves and there's going to be arguments back and forth,
but what you gotta do is someone's got to put forth an educated plan,
like a plan that's based on science and reason and a plan that you can debate
against opposers of that plan.
But when you have people that don't believe in science,
a lot of how do you,
how do you slowly but surely got to edge.
It's going to take generations.
This is what I'm saying.
It's like the,
the,
the momentum of our stubbornness and our,
our,
our past and the,
the sort of the systems that we find ourselves stuck in,
systems of behavior and thinking,
culture,
all that stuff is,
he's going to take a long time.
We sort the wheat from the chaff.
We've got to figure out what's good and what's bad and we're doing it.
We're doing it.
But it was doing it actively and it's frustrating because you're like,
God dammit,
this is the worst time.
We still have all these problems.
We still have cops shooting people.
We still have crime.
We still have Wall Street theft.
We still have all this stuff.
Yeah,
but you know what?
I liked him.
But you know what I like is we know about it now where it's not hitting like 20
years ago.
Like you heard him,
let's go 30 years ago you heard Nwa make that sound.
F The police and they're talking about the same things that are happening today,
except you would hear the song and go,
oh,
that's a great song.
That's not Rodney King.
Rodney King.
You watched him get the fuck beat out of him.
Yeah,
on TV.
And here's the thing about the Rodney king thing.
That guy apparently was like,
we had done a bunch of crazy shit,
right?
He'd gotten a car chase with the cops.
Beat the fuck out of somebody before that.
There was a lot going on.
You just got to see the end of it while this guy,
was he,
what was he on?
Was he on a drug and I think he was on PCP.
PCP apparently makes you look super humans strong.
I had a buddy of mine who got his finger bitten off while he's on PCP.
Said he didn't even know it.
Bitten off by who?
A street fight.
Yeah.
It's like he didn't even realize this fit cause he was,
he was on PCP.
Do you realize how many bit his finger off
then he went to?
Yeah,
he had,
uh,
his toe removed and his toe,
put onto his finger where it's finger used to be.
Was it a thumb?
No,
this is pinky fingers up his um,
trigger finger.
So on one of his,
any had it curved so he could always throw right hooks.
So is when you'd shake his hand.
He's a,
he would give you like this weird handshake while he would shake your hand,
but there was always one finger that wouldn't just try to tickle the middle.
It didn't move good because they,
it was really as toe that they replaced as a finger with a toe.
That must have looked weird.
It was weird.
It was real weird.
Yeah.
But that's PCP son living at PCP life.
Fucking crazy people in Boston,
man.
He was a boxing coach.
Ah,
yeah.
I don't know ma'am.
It's just we need to get to a better place.
Yeah,
we're getting to a better place.
But I think it's a long,
slow process.
I think we are in the,
I mean there's people that say you like,
hey to,
to minimize the suffering that people feel right now is just for you to say that
is outrageous and it's just a hallmark of your delusional perspective.
That's not true.
This is not denying the awful things of the world.
The awful things of the world exist.
But if you tried to look at this as a mathematical equation,
if you look above,
he would say,
well,
there's a lot of problems here.
There's a lot of competing factors.
There's environmental factors like what are they doing to the world?
What are they doing at the ocean?
What are they doing to the air?
Oh Jesus,
everything is warming up and people are fighting over what's causing it.
Like they're not even paying tent.
This is madness,
but look how much knowledge there is.
Look how much discussion there is.
Movements are moving and growing and people are,
even when they're misinformed,
it's still,
there's activity.
There's all this stuff going on.
Even when you know,
someone says,
Hey,
we're going to tax everybody that makes more than $10 million,
70% like bitch amp tax and shit.
Stop.
Just stop,
stop,
stop.
Just because someone works really hard,
you can't take all of it.
Look,
stop people from stealing money,
stop people.
But if you,
if people say,
well,
we want equality of outcome.
Okay,
as soon as we get equality of effort,
talk to me as soon as we can.
Cause some people don't hustle,
they just don't.
And I don't know why.
Maybe it's the way they were raised.
Maybe they have poor nutrition,
maybe they have a hook worm.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
But don't say that everybody's supposed to hit the right spot and everyone's
going to get to this spot.
And then after that spot we're going to divvy,
divvy up all the money.
So nobody ever makes more than a hundred thousand dollars a year in the world's
a better place.
Bitch.
That doesn't make the world better than those that makes lazy people happy.
That some fucking juggernaut like Mark Cuban or one of these billionaire
characters is like hustling constantly and gathering up massive resources.
Yeah,
he's playing the game of monopoly but he's playing a 24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
That's his option.
He can do that.
You can't stop people from doing that.
Well you can stop them.
It's from doing in just things with that money and maybe you can do is like help
someone like lean towards the like a Bill Gates type situation where he does so
much good and so much charitable work and it helps out so many people that you
go,
oh well maybe it's not a bad thing for a guy like that to have all that money
because you don't have to think of him as just mister money bags.
Like maybe you can think of him as he does have access to all this money,
but he's also this incredible resource for hope and change and prosperity for
some folks I think.
I think like,
I think people wouldn't mind giving money to something that they see being
built.
Like if there's work into it,
people hate the idea of just giving money and not seeing something from it.
Sure.
You know,
but when you've guilty,
even it's the people that don't know what the fuck to do with it and they just
going to find a use for it because that's what bureaucracy is.
I don't know man.
No,
no.
I don't know Joe.
We just,
I don't know either,
but I do know that it's fashionable to say it sucks.
It's fashionable to say everything sucks.
Well it's,
it's easy to say that,
but like you said,
but I really think it starts with if the government is not on the same page and
they're always fighting,
you can't,
you can't move forward that all this great stuff you're saying can't move
forward because it starts from the top Joe.
That's true.
But it starts from the top.
What's interesting is one of the things that's cool about the government
fighting as you get to see that,
like even the president can't do the things that he wants.
Yes.
He has to consult with people and they have to agree on something and it has to
be reasonable and you have to present it to the American people.
And so the people have to represent their constituents.
And so you're seeing this really fascinating thing because you've never had a
guy like Trump in office before.
So you see him say he's going to do things and then you see the rest of the
[inaudible] the fuck you are the fuck you are.
And then you watch this stalemate,
you watch this,
this go down and you watch these people being forced to negotiate.
And the way Trump was forced to talk about Nancy Pelosi,
cause she has so much power,
you know,
and you know he got to color our cut.
Oh yeah.
He left to call her at all,
which like to fuck out of it.
He has to pay their respect because he's stuck now.
Golf claps right in his face.
She's like,
it gives enough man.
I,
it's so fun.
It's so fun to watch right now.
It is a fun time man.
And what social media being so big.
How do you,
how do you deal with people like the haters?
Because there's so many people,
as I call them,
thumb thugs,
but how do you deal there?
Hating in the dark.
I don't know what they're doing.
You don't read all those comments too?
I don't read shit anymore,
man.
A very,
very rarely go into mentioned it.
And if I do,
it's usually a mistake.
I would just,
I just do my best.
I'll do my best.
I post and I go,
I post and ghost.
You don't even look at people's feeds,
do?
No.
I look at some people's feeds and Instagram when I'm bored,
you know,
I'm,
I'll,
I'll read some things,
you know,
I want to look at some cool pictures.
I'll watch some inspirational shit.
I like going to the rocks,
seeing him lifting weights,
pumped up.
I want to go to the gym.
Let me do that.
The Rock is a bit,
let me tell you it Fletcher,
I interviewed the Rock the first time I met him.
I was like 11 years ago during the game plan and we just hit it off,
right game playing the game plan.
That's where he played a quarterback.
He was a lot thinner.
His,
his first breakout movie,
he did Scorpion and then the game plan.
And after that interview,
uh,
he took some time and just talk to me.
He wasn't the rock then,
I mean sweet.
And then over the years,
every time I interviewed him,
he would pull me aside and go,
are you going into my acting coach?
Are you doing this?
Are you doing that?
Is there anything I can help you with?
And I'm like,
why?
Like,
and then he got bigger and bigger and the last time I saw him,
same thing,
Yo,
are you doing,
are you going to the acting coach?
Are you working on your goals?
Or you're improving like literally his Instagram,
but in real life and um,
and it's,
and he'll never know this,
but it's a thing that's for me just average Schmo Michael Yo,
to take the time out.
Every time I interview them to ask me if I'm achieving
my goals,
if I'm moving forward in life,
giving me positive things,
positive thoughts to take that time like five minutes after every interview and
this dude is booked nonstop,
but to actually take time and it's just so inspirational in to see him be the
biggest movie star in the world.
And he knows everybody's name.
He's very respected.
I don't know if he has an earpiece,
but like it's like he's like the president when he was,
he knows everybody's name.
He could be president.
He,
oh hundred percent hundred percent a hundred percent it could be present or he
can free form.
I would too,
because he believes he's just a hard also comes from humble beginnings.
Yes.
I mean he's in Hawaii right now and he's filming on his Instagram.
He's talking about all the neighborhoods that he goes back to to check to see
where he was worse from when he was poor and starving.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
He really is from humble beginnings.
I mean,
he,
he had only like,
you know,
it's the story like $5 left in his account and then he got discovered and
wrestling.
And I knew him in Miami when he was doing WWU.
I interviewed him a couple times over there and,
and he played for the University of Miami,
my favorite college football team.
So it's a thing where,
you know,
the history of 11 years,
but for him that big to take time to motivate me separately.
And you know,
I know if he sees me out,
he knows my name,
but it's not like I'm texting her,
I'm not like Kevin Hart with them.
And just to be a random dude that he takes time out every time he sees me to
make sure I'm hitting my goals and moving forward with my career and not bad.
And then offering,
hey,
if you ever need anything,
get in touch with me.
You know,
I would never take him up on that.
But it's a thing where I'm no body,
he's the rock.
And to be that inspiration,
I mean it,
it just does so much man.
Like it.
Little things that big celebrities do or somebody that really inspires you,
like they don't know how much that means.
Like just that little time he spins,
it needs some lows.
I think he does know.
I think he's a genuine leader.
He is,
you know,
it's 100% that's why so many people like him because what he says is it's
authentic.
Like it's really who he is.
There is nothing fake about that man.
And you don't have to be fake and stuff to be successful.
And if you want to work as hard as that guy,
you can be successful.
I I asked one day,
I was like,
do you just take a bunch of pictures at the gym?
Like Dan just posts throughout the day because you don't always get that beg for
taking pictures.
No Man,
that guy's picking heavy shit up.
That's too big.
But you know what?
I left.
That's just too big,
Joe.
It's not too big for it.
He's an action star Dude and he's the first action started at looks like an egg.
Like I would want him to save my life and real life.
What does he like?
Six,
seven or some shit like that.
He's a giant.
He's a little bit taller than me.
I'm so used to these giant is built like a fucking like legitimate superhero.
Like will Smith was my guy.
But I left Willsmith for the rock.
No,
no,
no.
But like,
like I had to do what you gotta do,
but burning,
building a burning building.
Who's going to save you?
Who's going to save you will spend,
might save you two
aliens coming at you,
uh,
independence day.
Did you not see,
will Smith Save the world?
Doug,
my look,
I love will Smith.
An earthquake.
Well,
if you want someone to hold one hand on the top of a building,
thank you.
And then hold your wrist with another and know that he's got you.
According to the movie poster.
That's the rock.
See,
I never saw will Smith holding the top of the building.
His shooting by the hand will Smith can shoot a gun.
He kept those,
those zombies.
He did.
I am legend.
Oh Man.
What a great mother fucking movie.
Oh my goodness.
Freight.
Fuck God.
Yeah.
By Will Smith and the rock need to make a movie together.
They now have no amaze me,
the biggest movie in the history of the knowing history.
And they bow out Tom Cruise get 'em all together.
Tom Cruise will Smith and the Ravi every interview.
Tom Cruise.
Uh,
no,
but only with my brain.
When I'm in my sensory deprivation tank,
he reaches out to me.
Does he really?
He makes a mind meld and he puts on his,
uh,
Scientology earbuds and he,
astral traveling today.
It's amazing.
Interview Time Cruise.
What's amazing about it?
It's because you hear so many different stories.
Do you wake up with your pants off?
No,
I didn't.
I wouldn't know.
Not,
not,
not that time.
What am I,
he said Matteis mate.
But he doesn't break eye contact with you.
That's what I like.
No,
he just like,
hey,
what's up?
Yeah.
And what he'll do is I get nervous.
No,
I'm not.
no,
no.
But that's what he's doing.
He's making you nervous or he's just wants you to know.
He's like,
he's locked in,
right?
Like he will not break eye contact.
Like if you look over it,
he'll be like,
probably makes it harder for you to ask fucked up questions to know what he
does.
And I tell all my friends
what he does.
I tell all my friends when you interviewed Tom Cruise,
he will take,
ask him a question.
He'll try to make it three minutes long so he doesn't have,
you can't ask him.
That made me,
so you've got to learn,
you've got to build a relationship with them.
So then you can ask him a punch.
See,
I've interviewed them so many times.
I'll walk it.
I remember one time I walked in the room and say,
Hey Tom,
I've got five minutes so we're going to have to answer these questions.
So I got to that point.
But he,
he's a great inner nice guy.
Did you ever get the Scientology?
No.
Never part of the deal.
You can't ask him about that.
Well I,
I heard a part of Scientology is for you to walk out the room saying how great
they are.
And I just did since I just did it.
Right.
Yeah.
So maybe it did.
It's just,
well that's just a philosophy on like how to influence people.
Right.
Positively influenced people.
You want those people really thinking the best of you.
Well,
good strategy.
Well everybody was like,
oh,
he's crazy as this is that every time I interviewed he's great.
I love,
I mean I love Tom Cruise.
Some of my favorite people are crazy.
Yeah.
Tell me someone's crazy.
That doesn't shake me.
I'm not like,
okay,
well I talked to them.
They're crazy.
My favorite people are all crazy.
Like literally crazy.
My favorite people.
So for someone tells me that someone's crazy.
I'm like,
okay,
what else you,
what's crazy?
Not Scary to me.
Like will Smith is awesome.
It's got to be crazy.
Will Smith.
Sure.
No,
no going on too nice.
Too Nice.
Too Smart.
No,
you can ask here.
Is He?
No.
Is he a scientologist?
I have no idea.
The problem is when the problematic,
the problem I had,
the problem I have would be in the entertainment before there.
They give you questions to ask and you have to ask them or literally it could be
your job.
So they flowed out like a bunch of real dumb ones.
Did they give you any room to like,
oh yeah,
you could do whatever you want,
but there'll be like,
hey,
you got to ask this question.
And it's like if somebody just got divorced and you gotta be like,
Hey,
what happened to a divorce?
And it sucks.
And you had asked women that.
Yeah,
that's why I stopped doing it,
man.
I couldn't one time.
Uh,
what's her name?
and uh,
God,
what's her name?
Uh,
shoot.
She was in devil's wear Prada now Meryl Streep,
but,
and Anne Hathaway.
So they gave me the dumbest question that Kim Kardashian,
Kanye West were on the cover of vogue.
And right before that it was Anne Hathaway.
And so they told me,
they go,
hey,
why don't you ask her what she thinks about the cover?
Because everybody was like,
oh,
this is bull crap that Kim Kardashian was on it.
I asked Anne Hathaway that question and she goes,
well,
you know,
I don't run the magazine so it really doesn't matter to me.
I'm like,
fine.
So I finished the question.
I'm walking down the stairs and killed,
then I hear it.
She goes,
why the fuck would he asked me that question?
I don't give a shit who's on that magazine.
And I was about to turn back around cause I kinda got mad.
But now I was like,
man,
she's fucking right.
That was a dumb ass question.
Maybe you could say I'm sorry.
They made me ask you that question.
So just too late and it was too late.
Yeah.
That's just felt so stupid.
Asking this question series like winding you up like a little robot,
click,
get out there and ask the question.
It seems don't ask.
Oh yeah,
they threaten your job with it.
Well that's why those shows are always so canned.
You know when you have people talking to entertainers and everything,
so canned.
It just seems so inauthentic.
Like they wanted me to ask my first interview ever was with Jennifer Aniston and
Marley and me and this is right after she broke up with Brad Pitt.
They want you to ask about price.
They wanted me to ask about and I was like,
no,
I can't do that.
Did you tell him?
No,
no,
I know it was my first gig.
So you had to,
so no,
I didn't.
So I said,
what if I figure out a different way to ask?
So I found,
so what I,
they were like,
whatever you get,
we need a clip.
You know?
And this was when I was at e entertainment and this is my first big shoot ever,
Jennifer Aniston.
And they were like,
you're going to go out there.
So it was Marley and me,
so she just broke up with Brad Pitt.
So I go,
uh,
since the movie's about a dog,
I go,
what's the,
uh,
um,
what's the similarities between a dog and a man?
And she labs and gives a great answer about you.
No one will be around,
but a is always forever.
You know,
like men could treat you wrong.
So I got a great answer from it and I didn't have to ask about prep.
And that's the thing is if you find a smart way to ask it,
you can ask it,
but they just sometimes want you to beat this.
So brutal.
It's,
it's I can't,
well it's because they don't have to do it and they don't keep the
relationships.
They don't care about things and they just don't,
they don't even care about you.
You're a little trained person that they send out a little monkey Patterson
little person listened to me as a person.
You have to listen to the person who signed the paper is to send you off and
give you little fucking direction.
Ah,
it's the grossest,
I mean it was amazing cause I got to build relationships with people.
But like good for you for recognizing it.
Oh a hundred percent a hundred I knew they were doing so once you may not,
I mean that by like recognize you got to get out of that 100% it's,
I see my soul couldn't do I cause I couldn't ask people about them breaking up
or something tragic happening in their lives.
Like how are you doing now?
Is running to some of them TMZ dudes.
It feel bad.
I'm like look Bro,
I feel bad too,
but I'm not talking to you like this.
There's nothing good ever comes out of these.
Like,
it's no disrespect to you.
I know you're doing a job.
I'd probably do the same job if I was in your place or pro.
Definitely.
If I was a kid when I was a kid of TMZ was around it,
I take that job.
Well,
we're going to do,
just try to ask some famous too funny question,
but it's just like,
it's not the way to discuss things.
We discuss things and you're coming out of the airport or you're on your way to
a fucking restaurant somewhere and someone sticks a camera in your face like,
come on.
Well,
I wasn't doing that.
I was,
I was.
We were going to junk it.
No,
no.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But I mean there's these,
these junkets are a brutal assault on reality.
This,
you're saying the same thing over and over and over again.
You ask him to say,
everyone asks you the same question.
You know?
Tell.
So tell us about this show.
Michael.
You play,
you play Michael.
Yo,
you're my real name.
This is crazy.
Oh,
by the way,
write this down.
Michael.
Yo,
average smo.
That's your,
your first comedy special.
You're going to call it Michael.
Yo average smoker.
Average smoke because that's what you said when you're talking about the rock.
He's like,
Yo,
average smile.
So that would be a funny second.
Oh,
that's right.
You already have one.
I just came out with it.
Yeah.
And when did it come out?
Uh,
it on Amazon prime.
It's free.
Came out two and a half weeks ago.
Oh Scott Blasian Blasian cause I'm black and Asian.
I get it.
Yeah.
Tiger woods say something like that.
No,
he said he's cut Blasian when Oprah and told her,
told her she wasn't,
he wasn't black and black people got so,
Ooh,
that's a tough one to swallow.
Well,
I tell you what it's tougher is I was up for a job is a very prominent black
producer told me I wasn't black enough for the job.
When I get old on theirs,
tanning booths close by.
I'll be back in four days and where rock you fucking world.
But he has to like,
if you go to like a tanning every day,
I could not get black car,
but I wouldn't get black.
Can get dark.
You could get dark but not black.
You can get black.
Well,
what do they want?
What do you want it black?
Like Wesley Snipes?
No disrespect,
but I guess they said,
but I think it was more than just skin color.
They wanted a certain,
there was a certain role they wanted to,
I don't like me.
You don't think,
oh,
straight up black dude.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean that's the thing,
man.
Look,
if you're making a story and you want these characters in the story,
like say if you have some big fucking goon who terrorizes people,
you can't get Kevin Hart to play that role and that doesn't make any sense.
No.
That's where the rock comes in.
Right.
Big giant dude.
You know what I'm saying?
Everybody has to have,
you know that's a weird thing about acting too.
It's like,
man,
you gotta hope somebody has something that you would do good in.
You know,
like you have to always hope that someone's got a project that you could slot
into that project.
Yeah.
Or You just got to create your own.
That that's true.
To the best.
Is Billy Bob Thornton.
That's Slingblade thing.
Yeah.
Do you know what he did?
No,
he apparently he was like working on some movie,
like at some bullshit part in some movie and uh,
he was like super depressed and started doing this fucking character man,
man,
you know,
he does that character from sling and then we'll do it in the mirror and shit
and practice it and decided to make a whole fucking movie about it.
And that movie,
the launched him like it was his own idea.
Well,
I mean,
it's kind of like what you're doing.
You just decided to do your own thing and now you control your own destiny.
That's where we all need to get to.
Like,
honestly,
this,
you know,
what I love about comedy right now is I like Jo Koy was my mentors and he's
blown up in comedy,
you know,
so I see people like you,
Joe,
and you know,
a pill per and just a Thiel Vod who took me out my very first time doing comedy
ever did it really?
Madison,
Wisconsin,
you know at uh,
I think it's called state on six or six on stage.
That's the first time you ever got paid.
That's the first time I ever got paid and he's the first person to ever take me
out.
And I remember we landed and he goes,
you're not,
you're going to see grown men eating cheese.
Like well like sharing bags of cheese.
That's it.
And what's got w as soon as we got off the plane,
literally two men on a bit sharing a bag of cheese and he was like,
I told you like it was very weird.
So weird.
The culture of cheese and Wisconsin.
Anyway,
it's so you're making now,
not the yells blown up like you're making your own path.
And I think with comedy now is the time where people can make their own path and
control their own destiny and we get paid really well.
I mean just go to the comedy store and look at the parking lot now.
Well it's what it is now is you not dependent upon networks anymore.
The networks that we've created or what I was like to refer to as an organic
network.
There's a network of friends,
like when you're talking about bill or Tom Seger,
RSF chefy or whoever,
these people are crystally all these like really successful popular comedians
right now,
Theo and so and so and so,
Andrew Santina,
these guys are all,
we're all friends with each other and everyone knows like if someone says this
guy is funny,
he's like,
well listen to the guys who are telling you these guys are all hilarious.
They know who the funny people are.
They know where the pretenders are too.
They don't talk about them and they avoid them and then you know who the funny
people are and you just,
it's an organic network,
like there's no paperwork,
but everybody helps everybody.
And one of the beautiful things about it is no one's fighting for scraps
anymore.
It's not like there's TV shows and there's only like if you and me are in the
audition room and we're friends,
but we're both auditioning for the same role,
like I don't really wish you were.
He well know.
I hope I might fuck with you.
I'm like,
do you sweating?
We'll be doing nuc nervous.
You okay?
It's an easy Gig,
right?
You're done nervous about that,
You're going to go in there and perform so you're not eating each other each
other.
You're not,
you're not scratching and clawing for scraps.
Everybody can support each other because first of all,
there's fucking thousands of places to perform just in this country.
Thousands.
And there's only a certain amount of Comedians,
like there's plenty of room forever.
Well,
what I love about,
uh,
like,
oh you guys doing the podcast and blowing up.
It's Jason Segel.
I used to interview him a lot when he was making movies and stuff and he said,
the thing about Judd Apatow is after freaks and geeks.
Judd basically made his own network,
you know,
James Franco and those guys and they supported each other no matter what.
And I see that same thing happening now and it's good what Comedians,
comedians are pairing up and saying,
this is our group and if you're funny,
you're funny and let's,
let's watch each other's back instead of competing is now like for,
you know,
I've only been in at nine years,
I know you've been in a lot longer,
but my nine years I saw at the beginning a lot of hate and now I'm seeing people
like now jump on each other's podcasts and it and actually encouraged each
other,
push each other,
which I think is a great shift for comedy right now.
Well,
that's the big difference between podcasts and radio because radio guys always
hated other radio guys.
They always taught him other radio guys.
Like,
I want that morning spot and this guy's going to try to steal it from me.
And he's a,
he's across town.
Fuck him.
Yeah,
podcast,
don't do that.
We get on each other's podcasts and we support each other's podcasts.
It's like there's plenty of people,
man.
There's this famine mentalities would fucked everybody up.
It is,
but that's what Hollywood puts out there.
You know,
it's just the circumstances.
It's not like it's an organized effort.
No,
it's not there.
This family,
it's just that this,
there was a search like we were talking about earlier,
like if you're an actor,
you've got to hope somebody got something that you fit in to.
Yeah.
So all the other dudes that are like,
you man,
you're competing against them.
And then you know,
you hear a fucking,
some James Franco type dude got the role.
You're like,
of course he's famous.
Fuck,
I can't,
I'm never going to catch a break.
And this is the,
this is the feeling that a lot of like really depressed act or sat.
Well,
it's interesting because I was up for these huge hosting gig like last year and
look like I was going to get it.
And then the night before they say,
oh,
we gave it to this bigger guy.
Like he was a celebrity's name.
No,
I won't say his name.
He's,
no,
nope,
nope.
No,
no,
no.
You know me,
Joe.
I'm very safe.
I'm still trying to make it like you.
He got an Indian.
My ages goes,
you don't sound upset.
I was like,
no,
because the way I'm wired is I need to get to that level where I'm getting jobs
I don't deserve.
I know what I mean.
I see why you wouldn't say his name.
No,
you playing it safe.
Put your nut.
But he knows who he is.
No,
he's out there listening to you right now.
You're better than,
you're better in the audition to him.
He did this better.
I said about you and that's what they're telling me.
What your agents are telling you.
No,
no,
no.
The casting people are telling me this,
but I don't try to fuck you.
No,
no,
sure.
I'm positive.
Positive.
So what I get to that point,
I'm just like,
I reversed and I was like,
dude,
when you get to a certain level,
you get shit.
You don't necessarily,
he probably didn't even know he was going out for the show.
They really like it.
Hey,
we've got a new contract and we heard you could do it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
maybe,
but that's this industry.
Once you get to a certain point,
you get gigs,
you start getting paid.
Once your podcasts blew up,
you can people send you stuff,
you know?
And that's how this whole thing works.
And so my mentality is I needed to get to that point where people start giving
me things and that means working harder.
Okay,
great.
Working harder,
building my brand,
doing stand up.
I'll do that.
Don't ever say building your brand.
Don't say that ever again.
Building my brand.
Don't do it.
Well,
okay,
don't,
okay.
That's some nonsense talk that they throw around brand.
You're building your brand,
man.
Hey Dude,
I really love with you doing your thing with your brand.
That's like a Hollywood thing that they say.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I love what you're doing with your brand.
Ill
the fuck man.
You don't think a brand is real?
Well,
brands are real like,
uh,
I'm wearing converse sneakers.
Those are real.
But see to me when I hear her say I'm wearing under Armour.
Yeah,
I like the rock.
You always support to Liz campaigns.
My buddy campaign sent me these will go that they're nice.
Oh wait a minute.
I like them.
No,
no,
no.
But like what I,
your pocket and your podcast is a brand.
I don't think of it that way really well,
but it is thinking about or not,
but he wouldn't show Rogan experience is a brand,
but building my brand,
like literally there's zero thought of that.
Okay,
got you.
You know,
you're just doing you.
I just just do what I want to do.
Hey man,
just be yourself.
Just be yourself.
It's,
it's possible.
I am absolutely just doing that.
You know,
I'm just really lucky that there's a slot,
right?
Like that I have interests that are like the like,
like the fact that I do standup comedy and I also do cage fighting commentary
that's not supposed to exist.
Right.
But to create it.
But it exists because there's a slot.
I got lucky that there was
a slot there.
You know that this exists,
this is a sport exists.
Then I have an understanding of it and a deep appreciation for it.
And then the comedy exist too.
And then I like that too.
Like you don't have to do comedy,
nobody has to do comedy.
But for me it was like,
oh,
like you could do that.
But isn't it an amazing like with like what,
I'll be honest with you,
when I came on I was like,
oh my God,
this is such a big show.
It's a huge show.
People get nervous.
I talked to a lot of people that come on the first time people get nervous
coming to the show,
but what are we got all that booze over there.
Well,
yeah,
but what's amazing is do you ever think about like if somebody is on your show,
literally whatever they're selling or like you'll get somebody on this show that
becomes a regular and now they're selling out all across the country.
And that's pretty amazing.
The power of that you hold.
You know what I mean?
Which is great.
Which blows me away that,
you know,
like the last time I saw that,
uh,
I remember,
you know,
I was at Chelsea lately at the beginning of it and when that show was at its
peak,
I say,
Chelsea lately,
Chelsea handler was the American idol of comedy at the end.
Then if you were on that show,
I didn't even do stand up,
like literally I was three months in a,
I would bring five comedians and do like 15 minutes in between everybody and
bring and sell out shows because I was on that shit.
That's how much power.
Like she brought comedians that were retired back.
She brought in,
that was the first time I saw like one show could be so powerful in a niche
audience where if you love comedy,
you're going to sell out all these people shows while it's hot.
And now it seems like this show is that like comedians come on here and they're
just selling out all over the place.
And that's a,
that's a tribute to you,
man and your audience,
how they're so passionate about you.
And I'm not here to kiss your ass,
but I all,
it's just not,
not bullshitting people and not having people on that suck.
Like doing your bet.
Like I try to go after,
like to get guys on,
I like you guys are,
I don't know,
hear about them.
You know,
like Andrew Schultz or Dell and I hear about these guys from New York and people
tell me,
hey,
you gotta see this guy,
this guy's fucking funny Joe list.
A lot of people told me,
get these guys on and you know,
look,
I am a whatever I can do to support comedy.
I'm a fan.
I'm a fan of comedy.
I love it.
Even if I was never doing it,
even though I decided right now,
I don't want everyone to tell jokes on stage ever again.
I will always watch.
I love it.
I love standup.
I'll always love standup.
So if I can do something and help stand up and helps comedians be successful and
it helps encourage more people to try it because I think there's thousands and
thousands of,
uh,
just unexplored standups across the country.
They just never take a chance.
Never do it.
Never have anybody encourage them.
Never think about doing it.
If you ever been on say I think it's a super power,
I really do because your census are so high.
I'm never been in a situation where when you're onstage,
you're saying your act,
you're thinking about something else.
You're hearing conversations like,
like you're hearing a waitress take order
and you're noticing what people are doing.
Like it's almost like an out of body experience.
Like I in,
I can't think of any other normal time throughout the day that would ever happen
where it's pretty amazing what your mind can do when you're on stage.
We have to train it.
Oh yeah.
No,
I mean that's one of the reasons why I have to do so much stand up.
Like even for me after 30 years of doing it,
I still have to do standup four days a week.
I do stand up for days.
Oh yeah.
If I don't do stand up for weeks earlier,
if I'd take a week off,
that's fine.
Nothing wrong with it.
I'll take a month off.
Nothing wrong with that.
But understand that when it's time to roll again,
we're gone four days a week.
We're going to do two,
three shows a night.
You're going to go Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
or you're going to do Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
That's what you're doing.
And that's the only way to do it because if you don't do it that way and you
don't do three sets a night,
two sets a night,
four sets a night.
If you don't do that,
you never stay.
You got to get laser beam sharp and the only way to get that D,
that honed fucking Samurai sword edge,
you got to constantly be doing it.
It's you,
that thing that you're doing where you're talking about hearing all these
things,
but concentrating on what you're saying and being in the moment,
which is the most critical cause they know when you're not in the moment they
somehow or another no one,
you're,
you could say the same words,
the same inflection and it won't work.
Oh,
that's what's amazing about it though.
That's what I love about it.
Like,
oh I love how you could do two sets in a night and get a totally different
reaction.
It's so exciting.
I was talking to Darnell Rawlins,
he was like,
he was talking about what night he had a great set and the next one he didn't
have too good of a set.
He says,
I went to a grocery store,
he got on the mic just to get a laugh.
You know,
it's like I need to get on a mic.
I needed to get one lap cause you can't go to bed on a bad show.
Don L is amazing on podcasts.
I tried to talk him into doing a podcast.
Oh,
he would be so good.
He's starting it.
He's already got a logo.
He's got it.
He's called it too soon with Donna.
We're always cause half his shit till he is so sunny.
Manny,
he's a character.
He's such a good dude to just stick a good dude.
You know who's who's,
who's a person that,
that I,
I know you're so established now you've got your craft,
but who's a person that like after they go on you're like,
oh shit,
I got to bring it.
Is that still that for you?
Because your crowd is soak about it with everybody.
But I don't think about it in terms of like,
oh shit,
I like comedy.
This is the key to following people like comedy.
Enjoy it.
Go on stage,
happy like you're laughing and then do your stuff cause it's,
you're working on in any way.
It's good,
right?
If you,
if you take enough time and enough effort,
enough care on your craft and put together an act,
it's good that people can enjoy it.
So don't worry.
Enjoy like if like I,
that's why I brought Joey Diaz and the road with me for so many years because I
knew that he was just going to erupt that place.
And by the way,
but when I went on stage,
they were already already in a great,
they're all laughing.
The laughing hard.
This,
the keys.
Just everybody should have a good time,
man.
Everybody,
including your opening act in the Middle Act,
you want murderers to go on.
And I,
you know,
like the comics I bring aren't as well known yet,
but Leo flowers,
Nick Care,
Orlando Labor.
But I tell you,
any room they crush,
they crush in.
Sorry,
one way for Greg Comics to get gray,
but it's like playing on the guy.
They got to see him.
Absolutely.
There's a lot of guys out there that people just haven't seen,
but they're good and I don't and I love coming in after energy.
What about,
what about the first time you went after a big comic,
when you were first starting and you did well and it kind of blew you away?
I don't even know when that happened.
I ate shit for so many years.
That's all I remember.
I remember eating shit after everyone.
Good.
I didn't have one good set for like Mitzi used to set me up to.
She would do it on purpose.
Um,
she would put you like one of those warm spot in my twenties.
I was,
um,
young little cutie face and I would go on after fucking murderers like Martin
Lawrence when he was in his prime,
when he was wearing leather jumpsuits on stage and leather shirts,
American,
the room,
I mean mark in the room where people are falling out of chairs and throwing
drinks at each other.
Dan Martin Lawrence was a church in the church.
She was an assassin man.
I'm telling you,
people forgot how good he was for a few years.
There was a few years where Martin Lawrence was nuke and crowds just like,
boom.
Yeah,
she and I would get on after him and literally people would,
just,
three quarters of the audience would get up and walk.
When he was off,
they were done.
They were done.
They were ready to go home.
There were,
they were crying.
They were holding their body like,
oh Jesus.
And then I would get on,
say some nonsensical,
like,
well,
let's get the fuck out of it.
Let's go eat.
And they would just leave.
And that was,
um,
the reality of my time at the comedy store when Mitzi would,
uh,
she wanted you to know you ain't shit,
don't get crazy and you gotta figure out how the fuck can you go on after all
these murders?
When did you figure it out?
It took a long time.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm going,
when I came here,
I was only six years into comedy,
so a really,
I didn't have any seasoning.
I was,
I was really like a scrub,
you know?
I was like,
I had some material I had like I could do an hour on the road,
but it was half of it was bullshit and I was trying to figure it out,
but adds a few good bits,
but they weren't good enough and I didn't have the confidence to go on after a
Martin Lawrence or a dice clay or anybody who was really good.
You know,
anybody who was a really famous,
I would get nervous or Jesus,
you know?
But that's that.
But through that I figured out a way to do it.
You know,
I figured out a way like,
okay,
I have to figure out a way to grab people and let them know that I know the
situation.
Like,
oh this unknown fucking loser has to follow Martin Lawrence.
What a thrill.
What a thrill for me watching everybody get up.
And so I can fill up material for like bombing,
like,
like inevitable bombing and recognizing the bombing and addressing it with all
the rest of the audience.
And then people started laughing,
you know,
like,
uh,
I had a fall prior for five in a row
when he was at the comedy store when he was really sick and um,
uh,
delayed,
great Mallarme Maryland,
Martinez,
her husband,
um,
and Chewy,
who was the door guy?
The common store you used to help Richard prior to the stage and it would take
forever because they would walk him cause you know,
it's losing control of his body and they sat them down and they would crank the
microphone up to like as loud as it goes.
So it was like he would hear the feedback
and he would drink,
would probably wasn't supposed to be doing cause he was on medication and just
drinking and just just talking and a lot of it was really sad because you
realize like,
wow,
this is the greatest comic of our time.
I mean,
yeah,
he's on the wall here in the studio.
Yeah.
I mean he's a,
if he's not the greatest ever,
he certainly in the conversation it's like who's the greatest,
I don't know.
But there's a handful of like super important pioneers is Lenny Bruce and
there's Richard Pryor.
Those are the two top,
in my opinion,
there's the ones that are the most important for the art form,
and this is obviously George Carlin and Kennison and he'd go down the line and
Eddie Murphy who were talking about for the show to still to this day,
I think it was one of the all time.
Great.
I was telling you before I got a chance to talk to Eddie like two years ago,
he came out with a serious movie,
more dramatic,
I forgot,
I forgot the name of it,
but it was really good.
And I asked them,
you know,
being a comment,
I was like,
why haven't you shot another special?
And he goes,
I have to put too much of my personal life in it and I'm not ready to do that
yet.
And it Kinda hit me where,
you know,
if you go back and listen to his comedy,
he talked about his real life.
He talked about his parents,
he did a lot of what Richard Pryor did.
Yeah,
he's very personal and you've got to remember it.
I think more of it.
A Lot's gone on in his life over the last 1520 years.
And I think if he didn't address things when he hit the stage,
people go,
why didn't he talk about that?
Where Chris Rock and Kevin Hart,
they will address whatever stories out about them and go full steam ahead.
And I think Eddie Murphy probably respects the craft too much where he's like,
I can't do it halfway.
If I,
if I'm not going to do 100% I'm not going to do it.
That's what I took from that conversation from him.
That makes sense and also just think about it.
He has two of the best specials probably ever made back then.
Like the two biggest where everybody still no good at Google.
Like people still can say that has a vibe.
You know like people still quit those two.
Yeah,
look,
he's a,
he's an all time great.
Even if he never does a joke again,
but he's still got it.
That's what's crazy.
100% he got,
did you ever see that thing that he did where he was roasting bill Cosby when
they took away his honorary degree?
Dude,
his timing was sharp.
Like you were like,
oh my God,
he could go do stand up right now.
But the pressure of that,
because he has two specials,
it's kind of like a compared to Dr Dre,
after Dr Dre made the crowded day,
I was like,
oh,
he's going to come out with another one.
And then it got to a point where,
how do you back up?
I mean the greatness of those two specials.
I mean it's a lot to live up to.
Not saying he ever couldn't,
but people are always going to say,
man,
you remember delirious and raw.
I wish he was like that.
You know?
And I think that's the fear mean maybe.
I mean you could make that argument about a lot of guys that did keep going,
you know,
to give me a lot of guys.
But those guys that kept going to have a delirious,
so raw,
you know like to network.
Like I remember first time going to a movie theater to see a standup comedy
special two times delirious and raw.
Like who does that?
Kevin Hart does it.
But like that's your,
that was my first,
Oh my God.
Eddie Murphy on the big screen.
And those are locked in the history of time.
People are going to know those two standup specials for raw for sure.
Delirious I think was on Hbo,
wasn't it?
I don't remember what's wrong.
I think delirious was,
I think it was an HBO special.
All I remember and I think rob was in the mood raw.
Okay.
So rob was in the movies,
but it's a kid like me going to the movies to see it and he was so big at the
time.
And just to follow those up,
that might've been part of the problem with him too.
He might've got too big.
That happens to certain comedians like that happened to Steve Martin.
Steve Martin talked about that.
I mean,
I don't think either one of us is ever going to understand and how famous Eddie
Murphy is like what it's like to be Eddie Murphy at that time.
No,
I mean,
come on now man.
People see him and they get weirded out.
I got weirded out when I met him,
put it in theaters for years after it aired on Hbo.
Delirious.
Yeah.
Theaters.
Um,
uh,
dice clay had an HBO or a movie theater film.
Um,
he did.
he did a,
uh,
oh did,
um,
dice clay had a movie theater one.
Uh,
Gabriel Iglesias has done one that's been in the movies.
Of course Kevin Hart has just been a few guys who've done them in the movies.
But yeah.
But I remember like,
you know,
Kevin Hart's was great.
Everybody,
but I,
for some reason,
maybe because I was a kid,
it was so big to me,
but to me it was like an event.
You know,
I'm older now,
I'll go to see Kevin Hart and a movie theater.
But when I was a kid,
stand up was an event.
I want to just like,
like that.
Yeah.
Cause you're,
you're hearing curse words.
The,
you know,
you're hearing all these years to this day,
still reciting stuff from him.
That's a lot of comedy specials.
You don't know the worst 30 years later.
Yeah.
Well I,
the first special I ever saw for sure was Richard Pryor live in the sunset
trail.
I saw my parents took me see it.
You were there?
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Washington.
The movie theater.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Now.
I was watching it in the movie theater.
My parents took me and I couldn't believe it.
Like I had never seen anything that funny.
I couldn't imagine it.
It's so hard today for an anyone to understand what it was like to hear that
stuff back.
And when I was at 79 or some shit,
when was a one was live on the sunsets trip to that bear joke.
Every I'm up the fire.
Yeah.
He was doing jokes about burning
himself and we were crying,
laughing.
Hilarious.
What year it released in [inaudible] 83 was it really live in the sense of taped
an 82 really good.
Okay,
so I was mean.
That makes sense.
He had to tape it twice.
No,
I wasn't 13 olds.
What else?
Like 80 45 1515 I was 15 years old.
Well,
let's see.
I was,
I was nine so I saw,
I saw both of those movies and I remember,
I remember Richard Pryor.
I was like,
wow,
Eddie and Richard,
you could tell Eddie studied Richard because they had the same mannerisms.
They had a couple of the same jokes too.
Just in a different way.
You know what I mean?
So it was kind of a thing where I fell in love with Richard Pryor cause that was
my first six but I was nine,
you know,
and I saw sunset strip and then I saw the documentary where he had to shoot a
two nights in a row.
The first night he bombed and he told everybody to come back the next night.
And that's the one they shot.
He shot,
he shot,
he shot it two nights in a row.
First one that he apologized to the crowd.
It wasn't going well.
And the second night he said,
y'all need to come back and we're going to try this again.
And so why would he want the same crowd?
Because he felt like he did a disservice to them.
But what,
that's so weird that he brought it back to Sam.
Yes.
And he meets,
he showed his true hundred percent.
It's in this documentary.
You don't believe it?
I believe it.
I can't.
I mean that's what was in the documentary.
Yeah.
But kind of like wouldn't want the same crowd to come back.
Well he his same material unless he stopped it short.
Well no,
he didn't finish the shot.
He didn't finish his wrong with him.
He said he was just off like he,
it was him.
It was him.
And he goes in and they were talking about the first like 15 minutes of the set
or 20 minutes of the set did not go well and he just stopped it and said,
look,
I'm not bringing it tonight.
It's off.
Y'All come back tomorrow night.
Jesus Christ.
And they kept the cameras and they shot it the next night and that's,
and that's what you have in 19 so in 1983 I was either 14 or 15 and here it is.
Sorry,
I came out in 82 this
was 82 that means I was 14 yeah,
I was eight.
Yeah,
it was either 14 or 15 which makes sense.
This is a fun fact.
I definitely know it was pretty pussy for me.
See the film editor train of thought,
forgot most of his material.
He apologize to the audience and end of the show early leaving the audience
angry prior pull themselves together and gave a much better performance the next
night.
Most of the footage in the film was from the second performance.
Yeah,
completely messed up his performance during the first filming of the show.
Yeah.
But that doesn't say he brought the same audience back.
Well and the documentaries that he said,
well,
because it was only one show.
What do you mean they didn't shoot to show specials?
Like they only take one night.
Well he said they filmed one and then they filmed it again.
He filmed it again the next night.
So that crowd,
I mean,
how are you going to get a crowd?
He didn't get a crowd
in the documentary.
He said he told everybody because he felt so bad that he write,
he cares.
He just stopped the show and he stopped the show.
It was like,
yeah.
And he bought what?
The document,
it says he brought the same crowd back the next night and he murdered it.
And that's what you saw?
Yeah.
Wow.
And I still remember that.
I mean those two,
like a raw,
delirious in the sunset strip life forever,
it will stand out in my mind.
It's just,
it's just amazing.
And then like bill burst special,
the,
the black and white one,
it's like incredible,
incredible.
You know?
And I just,
I love watching comedy of people with jokes that I know I never could do.
That's my own thing,
you know,
I don't like watching cause I'm a family comedian,
so I'd never watched like family to me,
I talk about family most of the time,
like don't come.
I don't curse that much.
How often you curse and an hour show twice maybe.
What,
what words you use?
Shit.
Yeah.
You have to say fuck no,
no,
no.
But I say person real nice.
Freaking this freaking guy.
Do you have said that?
No,
don't say frickin whatever you do fricking,
that's an fee more offensive to me then.
Fuck yeah.
Oh No,
I just fricking guy.
It's not in my,
I'm sure I curse a couple of times in this pod,
but I don't,
it's not in my normal conversation.
Like I,
even when I'm hanging out with my dude's,
I don't really curse that much.
Yeah.
Hmm.
I don't know,
and I'm sensitive.
It's like it's a lot going on with them.
Secret.
I had my kid,
I'm so sensitive,
man.
I don't miss that.
Did you change?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It changes the shit out of you will see some biological change.
It's also like you girls,
all girls.
It's also,
it's a recognition change.
Like you,
you kind of understand life in a different perspective that I don't know if it's
really available to you if you don't have children.
I just think it is.
I just think it's,
I don't think everybody has to have kids.
I'm not one of those zealots.
It says,
if you don't have kids,
you were in.
Shoot,
I don't.
I think that's offensive.
I don't think that's what life's all about.
I think you can affect people in a very meaningful way.
Never have kids and there's nothing wrong with that.
But I think for me,
at least for being the caveman that I am,
it's like it was very important for me to see these little girls grow up and
become,
you know,
human beings that are interfacing with the world and getting an understanding of
what that means and like realizing that if you can do just a little bit to make
the world a slightly better place,
that could greatly affect all the people that your own children will come in
contact with as well,
and they can actually affect other people and have those other people treat the
world in a different way and treat people with more respect and be nicer to
people and you can,
we could have a better world for everybody.
Well,
I,
your kids,
my kids,
everybody's kids.
The thing that struck me right away as soon
as my son was born is I've never had the feeling of you.
I would,
as soon as I would die for him,
like as soon as I met him,
you know,
I would die for as soon as he touched me.
It's like a goddamn prince song,
but it's like two presses gone too soon.
Yeah.
What about that guy?
God,
you want to talk about it?
Super powerful fucking entertainer.
One of a kind human being.
I remember I was a kid,
I was delivering newspapers.
I was driving around and I was a w uh,
listen to Attica set of a,
I wanna be your lover,
which is like his first big hit.
And I was like,
Holy Shit.
Listen to this guy.
Like listen to this guy.
And the covers is him with his long hair,
with no shirt on,
looking beautiful and the covenant,
what is he like?
What is going on here?
And I was almost,
you know,
it was,
I was like fucking 18 or something.
I was almost like turned off by the cover.
That's it right there.
I was like,
this is just,
I'm not buying this beautiful dream had gotten to a mustache.
I'm having weird feelings.
Right?
And then I listened to,
I would listen to,
I wanna be your lover and I was like,
God damn.
What an unusual dude.
Did you see purple rain?
I'm sure.
Yeah,
of course.
Like that whole Morris Day Apollonia like I want it to be prints I bought,
I bought an overcoat.
Just you're aware.
A long overcoat.
So at some prince where,
where are you?
Too Old for the Michael Jackson thing.
I had the thriller jacket no more that I thought it was,
I thought the Michael Jackson thing was interesting because I thought he's
obviously a stunning,
incredibly talented performer,
but he was so weird and so unrelatable and every way like so oddly feminine and
childlike,
even though he's in his thirties it was baffling to me.
I was like,
I get that he's super talented and then when the plastic surgery started
happening,
it's faced are changing and morphing.
I'm like,
this is just strange.
Did you ever see either one in concert?
No.
I never dressing prints.
I saw prince was an amazing,
I had an opportunity to see prince at the hard rock cafe and I blew it the hard
rock in Vegas and blew it.
I should have seen him.
I never thought it was going to die.
Yeah,
and that's,
I'm seeing everybody now.
Yeah,
you should.
Tom Petty's is another one.
I never saw Tom Petty.
I went to one of those apprenticeships at the palladium like four years ago.
He did a random seven nights.
There wasn't anybody there.
There was maybe 500 people there.
Really?
The whole floor was empty.
I don't know if why.
I don't know why.
I don't know if nobody knew at or something.
They didn't announce it at the right time.
It didn't make it to Twitter,
whatever it was.
I only heard because my friend worked there.
I only,
that's the only reason I knew about when we're looking at prince now,
we're looking at prints as like a dead legend.
I mean,
he's a legend that's gone and we think of him.
It's like God damn it.
He was so good.
He had so many great songs,
but I think then people thought of him as an older guy that they would,
didn't really care as much about anymore.
Who hasn't put out rail relatively popular music for quite a while.
He turned into an artist,
I guess they could say where the music was just for himself and he wasn't really
trying to new.
Right.
It wasn't a new smash hits.
You know,
it's like there's some guys,
right,
that like one of the things that keeps Kanye west relevant is it,
he's constantly putting out music constantly puts out stuff that people love.
He constantly puts us stuff that smashes and some guys lose their enthusiasm for
productivity,
for being prolific.
They,
they lose that and then they don't put out stuff anymore and then they become
like Rod Stewart,
like Rod Stewart.
I'd like to see Rod Stewart.
I'm a giant rod toured fan like it when Maggie may comes on the radio.
I get excited.
I love that Goddamn Song.
I love a lot of his music he was at.
But how many tickets we sell right now?
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
he sold out the staples center.
I don't think you wouldn't know.
You know,
you know when you,
I know you're still working on Kanye coming on the show and that's how,
even though you're not okay,
you know,
blood.
If he wants to do it,
but I don't want to put any pressure on anybody.
Absolutely.
And I don't necessarily know that podcasts are the best place for someone,
for everybody.
They might not be the best place to just talk about shit.
But did you get better to just do music?
Did you get to talk to him at least on the phone or talk to him?
Yeah.
Nice guy.
Let me tell you,
man,
he is so opposite his persona,
like on the outside like that you see in like in gossip magazines and on TV I
used to host has done to west foundation a event in Chicago and a lot of people
don't know the good he did in Chicago.
If they had perfect attendance,
he would go there every year,
throw a huge concert,
bringing like a common and all different types of Chicago artists.
He would,
uh,
bus everybody in from all over the city and throw a free concert for all these
kids that had perfect attendance.
And it was good to interview him that way because he sucked at that time.
At that time when his mom was still alive.
He's such a down,
down to earth humble guy and actually shy and shy.
Like he was really shy,
still wet.
And this was at the time I would see stories about him yelling at sway.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
this is not,
the dude that I interviewed was,
he's volatile and it goes all over the place.
Yeah.
That's part of why he's such an explosive artists.
Oh,
he's incredible.
Incredible guy.
Those are the people who think different and but that stupid apple ad think
different.
Yeah.
There's people that really do think different differently.
That's one of the problems with that apple ad to English grammar.
But they,
there's people out there that just have a different vibe there.
They're on a different frequency.
There are different wavelength and they're the ones who create great shit man.
He has a gift.
I mean he is,
you know,
a lot of people outside go,
oh,
he's out there.
He's definitely out there.
He's out there.
Yeah.
But he's a genius.
He is a genius.
He's doing something in a different way and that's,
that moves our cultural long.
That's what it's like.
That's what when you're doing standup,
right,
like if you're,
if you're nailing something,
if you really locked down something and boom,
you put out a live on the sunset strip or a delirious or somebody that you're
changing culture,
you're,
you're making people.
People are going to spread out in these ripples.
Yeah.
We're going to go to their job in the morning.
They're like,
we saw Michael Yo,
holy shit.
He does his joke about his cat and whatever the fuck it is,
whatever the joke is and people be crying,
laughing and that there's ripples to that as positive ripples you change thing.
It's amazing that like when you do stand up,
like what I love about it is when I was just a host doing the entertainment
shows,
I would go into castings and I go,
oh,
you're a host.
Go ahead.
Now being a comedian,
it's the most,
I will say that it's the most respected thing in our industry.
Like I was on the most balls.
I was on the set of modern family.
When the show was huge and the actors are like,
Oh my God,
you do stand up.
How do you do that?
And they're on the biggest television show at that time.
Modern family,
even actors respect to,
so how castings of change I go in now,
they go,
oh,
we saw you at the Improv where we saw you here,
there and you can host.
This is amazing.
You know,
so just the respect you get from doing good comedy,
you know,
it's,
it's better to me then a Taylor swift on stage because she has a whole band.
She's having a bad night.
She can kind of like lip sync sync or songs.
They have a bad shock quote.
It says Michael Yo says he's better than Taylor swift.
And all she does is lip sync.
God Damn Him.
You know when he was on he,
he respected her.
Alvin has gone,
he's flipped.
It's flipped.
We got to wrap this up,
dude.
We are hit three hours.
Isn't that crazy?
Three o'clock toad.
What the fuck?
Three hours.
Three o'clock.
Two o'clock Goddamn time warp in this room.
Dude.
Bagley out.
That was a lot of fun.
Thank you so much.
Thank you,
my friend.
I would tell people how to find you on Instagram,
Twitter,
all every day at Michael.
Yo,
that's why.
Oh,
am I specialist stream and free on Amazon prime and now,
right now Blasian but it's got prime.
Yeah.
Everybody's got prom.
Check it out,
man.
I would appreciate it.
Thank you my friend.
That was fun.
I'm glad we did this dude.
Me Too,
man.
I go,
Yo.
Ooh.